You're fucking freaks.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com,
which is right now,
the only way Brian sells those,
those,
uh,
kittycat tee shirts that you see,
those death squad shirts
from death squad.tv.
He actually uses stamps.com so
we know it's a good product.
If you use the code word Jre,
there's a little microphone in the
upper right hand corner was old school.
He microphones for whatever reason,
that's like the cool microphone.
I don't know why I never got that,
but regular microphones don't
get nearly enough fucking credit.
There's something sexy about those old
school Frank Sinatra in the 1930s back
when people were dumb as fuck.
That was a really awesome microphone.
So it's like a talk shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's classy.
Uh,
if you click on that and
entering the code word j r e,
it was a special offer.
You get all kinds of cool shit,
like a free scale and 80 bucks
and $25 in postage coupons.
And if you look at the website,
go to,
um,
go to stamps.com and then click on the
thing and entering the code word jre.
It'll fill you in on all the details.
Uh,
about the,
uh,
the opera w the way it is.
It says,
I have it says $110 bonus offer.
Why does it say $80?
Because he normally just a normal person
that goes to stamps.com he only gets
that $80 a offer.
But if you've typing or you click on
that microphone and type in j Rue,
you get a even better off.
Then you get $110.
I got confused.
I was like,
did they lower it?
I hate it when people like lower it,
you know,
when they have like,
I don't want to call them
out on it because there are
our customers or were you
know,
their customers or something
like that working together.
Yeah.
Uh,
anyway,
if you go to stamps.com but it allows
you to do is you measure all your shit.
Like,
say if you say it,
sell things like,
you know,
send things online.
You measure all your shit at home,
you put your little sticker on it,
boom.
Postman picks it up.
You don't have to go to the mailbox.
You'd have to wait in line.
You'd have to weigh your shit.
You could do it all right there.
Print up your own postage and
be done with that whole process.
Use The code word J,
r e and save yourself some money aren't
your Fox were also brought to you by
onnit.com that's o.
if you haven't been to the website,
we don't know what the
fuck to call the company.
So we call it a human
performance enhancement company,
if that makes any sense.
Human Performance Company,
uh,
the whole company is just focused on
shit that makes your body work better.
Uh,
exercise equipment that's the
best for functional strength,
nutritional supplements that are passed
for recovery and for cognitive function
and endurance and all that shit.
Very,
uh,
all of it is very healthy stuff.
It's like whatever we feel like we would
buy whatever we feel like we would use.
And I think,
you know,
it's beneficial as far as like exercise
equipment or vitamins or supplements.
That's the kind of stuff we sell and we
just try to sell you the best shit we
can find.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you saved 10% of any and all supplements.
Any,
any shows coming up?
Uh,
yeah,
I'm going to be a at,
not to Braya,
but what's the other one?
Ontario.
No,
no.
Braya I'm going to be in Bray Bray Improv.
What are you doing?
Improv and going to Toronto next month
and a comic con 2013 all the shit can be
found at [inaudible] dot TV or my
Twitter is red ban and all my shit.
That's a,
all my a upcoming dates are
all on Joe rogan.net all right,
that's,
let's just bail on this everlasting here.
Goddammit.
Commercial is now officially over
[inaudible]
stab lab.
Now,
Rod Gangsta Lean,
she
got a stick on a Mama.
The tattoos
seen as she was pushing the stroller,
smoke.
No cigarette drinking a Saluda
lab.
Nat,
a jewel,
Betas name tattooed on
the back of the shoulder,
top
black devil
number tattooed.
See here,
east side of the city,
Rau.
I'm in both.
She don't
got no,
I'll show the crowd
now.
Bag of groceries.
Zane post office,
man,
she's Santa's little money
and she made him sweat.
A phone is
most litigious,
matte black and sales should bang.
She says
she never Bam Solon alone.
No,
she got Megan.
She's girl.
Common mad girl of the Tattoo to you.
Yeah.
Snag Rau.
Woman.
Bolshie
no
sag.
Who got
me?
Oh,
shoulder
back to me.
She's a sad girl cause man,
no man.
Powerful.
So great to have you back,
man.
That was awesome.
Thank you sir.
Did a wine but Lasko joining me.
Brian.
It's up high.
You Doing Gentlemen Javelin?
You know this is a strange times.
It's good to have a man like
Everlast around trying to be,
trying to think,
trying to make it happen.
These are strange times,
my friend every day.
How are You Ben?
Good.
Live in Levin.
Yup.
Dan Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I'm surrounded my crazy women.
That's how I've,
you know,
if you could say that you've
probably had a fun life.
I'm surrounded by and completely insane
women with the ones that I'm not crazy
or not fun to be around unfortunately.
Just had a new one,
you know?
Got a three month old at home graduations,
ma'am.
Thank you.
Yeah,
everything's going good man.
Um,
you know,
just,
just turned rambling mines as well.
Has it been a year?
It's probably been about a year.
Yeah.
Somewhere around there.
Last time.
Too Long.
Yeah.
This is the first time at this
place to made an acoustic record.
We're going to have just
because of y'all rarely.
That's ridiculous.
When does that come out?
Um,
like August sometime.
I don't have the exact date,
but y'all will have it.
You know what I mean?
So you started doing acoustic shows,
you know,
I would do acoustic stuff,
like,
like walk in the radio station,
promote your record.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And then like,
um,
came and did your podcast first time,
didn't do any music and I mean,
people were still super love,
you know what I mean?
And then that second time when I came
and did music the first time and kind of
busted the cherry and the Joe Rogan
show in the musical world also,
you did,
you know,
like the reaction was ridiculous,
man.
I mean,
we've been doing coke,
Cousteau tours,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like it's literally like we toured all
the Europe and the winter and sold out a
lot of shows.
There's a lot of Joe Rogan
lovers in Europe too,
man.
But you know,
man,
there's,
there's something really
cool about acoustic music.
There's something really cool about when
you're doing a song and it's just you
and your guitar and that's it.
You now or in,
in a keyboard back up or whatever.
When you're right there doing
it live and raw like that on a,
on an internet radio show,
it's all just,
broadcast is no stop.
There's no,
let's try this again and
let's get it from the top.
When you drill down and it's just a good,
the way it says something about a us,
a sing,
a real singer songwriter and a guitar.
It's one of the purest
forms of expression.
The way it like hits you like
emotional impact of songs.
A dude with a guitar with a voice like
yours and a guy who was always writing.
That's when I dig about you.
You're always writing.
You've always got new shit.
You're always coming
in here with new songs.
You always have like
you're always working,
man.
You were just always putting in
the work when it comes to you
music.
You know what I mean?
It,
I mean you make people laugh,
you go look for crazy shit.
You know what I mean?
Something you're so
tells you you got to do.
Yeah.
You could make some money
at it as the bonus is the,
but uh,
there is the artist side of it that
it's like if I don't wake up and hustle
something out of nothing out of thin air,
you know,
then rent might not
get paid in six months.
That's true too.
And we've all seen people drop off.
It's scary.
Once you're moving,
you've got to keep moving once you know,
more money,
more problems.
You know,
one other thing is I
said something to Irish,
whole lot of fucking problems.
Yeah.
Anybody who doesn't want those problems,
don't be silly.
They're better than the starving problems.
I was telling the army should fear that.
You know,
we were talking about like
writing material and we just,
in the middle of the conversation,
I'm realize I'm like,
you know,
if you're an Ra ship for your fan,
you're the only one who could deliver it.
Like it's your responsibility.
You have like thousands
of Ari Shaffir fans,
but you're the only one who can deliver
you like you a particular style of
comedy.
You are what you look like,
the way you speak.
It's either the only one,
this is it.
So like for someone who's an Everlast fan,
you're the only one.
There's no other,
there's no other Everlast out there.
You the only guy who can
produce Everlast material.
So that's like a giant responsibility.
And if you're a fan,
you want to tap into a dude
is always creating new shit,
you know,
that way,
if you become a junkie,
like if you're a Leonard Skinner Junkie,
fuck man to sit,
they,
you know,
that fucking plane crash
was a long ass time ago.
But if you're an Everlast fan,
you're always begging out new shit.
You know,
we work in trying to be like,
you man.
I don't even know what that means,
but thanks.
I'm not even trying to be like me.
I'm just trying to make sense
of the whole fucking thing.
Cancer.
Have you seen the,
uh,
the thing that's going
down right now in Turkey?
Do you know what's happened to the riots?
Rebellion.
Massive rebellion and Turkey.
I have not read much about it.
Uh,
this,
it's,
they're saying it's some sort of like an
occupier style revolt and I saw a photo
of a,
these people walking down
the street and it's insane.
It's like some end of the world.
Shit.
It's like Brian,
see if he could pull up the picture.
It's crazy.
This picture of these people were
walking down the street together.
I mean,
it was overflowing with people.
It's like everyone was out
there marching in protests.
It was like 100% of the people in the
city and seeing them walking down the
street.
It's,
it's fucking craziness,
man.
I don't exactly know what
the fuck the story as though.
It's kind of strange to me too.
It's like,
I mean,
I don't know what,
maybe it's just my perception of things,
but it seems like the
less we are like that,
like our country that used to be that
kind of country where there'd be,
we got in an uproar.
They protested.
You know that though.
I mean it happens but let's keep it real.
It doesn't happen.
Like using the more,
the rest of the world takes
advantage of their freedom.
Like the less we actually use ours at all.
Well I think we're just so soft.
It's so sad when you're by like,
you know,
powdered donuts at 3:30 AM you know,
at the Ralph's every other block.
It's,
yeah,
life gets easy.
It's,
that's not good for you to be,
for things to be that easy,
you know?
That's why like an easy job.
It's probably one of the
worst things you should ever,
you know,
you don't want an easy job.
You don't want something that
you could just have brain it,
you will slowly rot away while these
kids in Turkey or throwing Molotov
cocktails at the cops and trying
to take over the government.
You know those are,
it's like,
but it's always going to be that,
right.
We wishing good luck to them or not.
That's the,
I said I'm not,
I don't know what I'm going to go.
I'm going to go with yes.
Just because I'm a rebel.
I'm down with that.
Brian,
are you a rebel?
I am ready to go with,
yes.
Awesome.
We're done with the younger,
you have a bomb on your hat.
So funny by the way,
and being on the airplane with
his hat was really uncomfortable.
I forgot that I had it on and it's just
like writing after the Boston bombings
too.
And I was like,
why am I wearing this kind of taste?
Good choice.
Did you have the Cammo
jacket to go with it?
No.
Like a hunting.
Like a duck.
The duck dynasty,
like hunting jams
with an empty scabbard.
Yeah.
Check my sword.
Jesus.
What about those fucking guys that
just hacked the dude up and Oh yeah,
in England.
That to me was like,
what the fuck is wrong with?
And hope it's really crazy.
If you seen the video of the
guy talking to the camera.
I didn't hear the talking about the
image but I didn't hear any of that.
What?
Like the rant or anything?
Yeah.
I don't know what happened man.
But apparently it was
something to do with religion.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm kind of know distant from religion.
I used to experiment
and all kinds of them.
I don't reject any blue
or a Muslim for a while.
Why am I mean?
I won't,
I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't practice cause I just
don't believe in organized
religion at this point.
Right.
I believe,
I do believe in God and I believe
in a single creator and all that.
Damn.
But there's a lot of stories
I don't believe in magic.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what I think about religion.
You know,
when I was a young man,
I was forced into Catholics and I don't
believe in killing motherfuckers because
my shit is right and yours is wrong.
You know what I mean?
Unless it's you're breaking into my house
trying to steal my shit then then I'm
a fair.
You're fair game.
Well,
when I,
when I was a kid I was forced to go to
Catholic school and I hated religion for
a long time after that and
just thought it was ridiculous.
The nuns were cons.
It was a mess.
It was just,
I was raised Catholic.
I got a story to it.
Did you go to Catholic school?
Yeah,
so I've,
I've for longest time,
yeah,
go ahead.
I'm sorry for the line is time.
After that I thought that
religion was horse shit.
You know,
I thought this is nothing in this.
But then as I got older I realized
that it's just because I had a terrible
experience with it.
And if you look at like a lot
of the principles of religion,
you got to decipher the fact that people
been around for so long just telling
stories and by the time it gets written
on paper or people's try to twist
things,
they're the way that they would like it
to be when it comes to translations and
things like that.
And it goes in different languages.
But the core of it all,
it's like people trying to figure
out how to get along to connect.
Yeah.
People trying to figure
out how to express love.
People trying to figure out how to,
how to treat one as you
would like to be treated.
You know like literally the tenants for
life that people figured out before they
really knew much of anything
about how the world works.
They had these ideas and
they said they came from God.
You know,
and whether or not anybody had
one on one experience with God.
I don't know.
I mean mate Shit,
who the fuck knows it's there.
Just the at the earth exists at all.
It's pretty fucking crazy
as far as I'm concerned.
It's nuts.
But I mean,
I compare it to this.
It's like I,
I don't say I know anything about a god.
I have a sense that
there's a higher power.
I have a sense of it,
you know,
I feel like I do.
I feel like there's something there.
But can I understand it or
explain it or define it now man.
Cause you know,
I always say,
you know,
somebody wants told me that's
like your shoe defining you.
Right.
You know,
there's gotta be a line before
between whatever a creator is.
And when the creation,
I don't even assume it human
characteristics anymore.
I just take it as like,
you know,
kind of like whatever
energy I'm following.
I never,
I never went to school for music.
You would to tell I was,
I never planned to do any
of this shit with my life.
And I don't say go around.
I'm not preaching or anything,
but I'm saying alls I did was follow a
certain path in energy and led me through
every religion.
It led me through every religion
and by the time I got to Islam,
Aye.
I took it into my life and it's
primarily about peace and love.
And then there's all this other sub
cultural crazy stuff that goes on in these
other places.
I approached it from a Western mind in a
western philosophy of like just this is
a philosophy to deal with.
It's not like my,
my clan didn't get murdered by that
guys Emam 14,000 or 1400 years ago.
You know,
there's all these sub stuff that goes on
between these Sophie's and Sunni's and,
and that's when I was like,
you know what?
Organized religion as a whole is
garbage because it meant they're just
organization to it.
Somebody in charge and then
there's power struggle.
Yeah.
Whenever you put it in individual vantage,
religion should be mine.
It's not even up for discussion.
And last,
we're going to sit there and be like very,
you know,
unless there's no,
I sat down with you.
I know we could sit down and
have a cool conversation,
but you know,
there's also 400,000 people that listen
to this or of millions of people that
listen to this and,
and you know,
you can't have a reasonable argument
with every single one at the light.
You know,
I think that the idea of the organization,
like when you put something
into a giant organization,
then you set rules up.
All of a sudden things get weird,
you know,
that's when people get into power and
its influence gets manipulated and,
and the,
you know,
like I tell people all the time,
you can consider me Muslim,
but I'll go out,
I'll go out tonight,
which you and we'll drink three whiskeys.
I don't care what you eat,
bank.
And what will you meet Allie?
Pepperoni.
Yes,
I will.
You know,
my wife,
that's my wife,
the half Jewish lady,
uh,
you know,
reintroduced pepperoni's into the life.
So I made a moderation recently to the
lyric was I'll never eat a pig and less a
pig as a cop.
So it Kinda just,
it leaves a little open door.
I was in Seattle and some lady came
to the show and gave me venison,
pepperoni that she had made with venison.
Her husband was a deer hunter.
God Damn,
it was good.
There was so much of it.
I ate it all.
We see you throwing shit on the grill
on Instagram and I just haven't got that
call ever.
Like,
come on,
have some of his venison steak with
me and my underwear two o'clock in the
morning and just being
out there with nature,
that's my,
you know,
my mind is my real time.
My spare tire man.
You know what I put,
I bought,
I posted a picture reasonably
like a Willie Nelson,
like on oh my.
That was like,
man.
And I'd looked at it
afterwards and I was just,
man,
I look so young and Dan and go,
I gotta drop like to Apple.
Even hashtagged it on there.
I got to drop like 20 pounds.
I meant to ask you this,
you're,
you have this artificial
valve and your heart.
Does that prevent you from doing
any kind of actual reasonably Joe?
My Engineer Guy,
one of my entourage,
he's that guy hard into
[inaudible] and uh,
and he was doing P90x in the morning and,
and insanity at night.
And that guy right there,
Tam.
So like he got me kind of pumped up.
I started,
I went from p nine Dx,
it lasted about one day.
And then I went to my doctor
because it discouraged me.
I was like Yo.
And he just,
I got it.
I got to find a dude who like,
I'm interested in your guy who's coming
in here and a couple of days that the
fitness dude,
oh I need to find dude,
he knows how to build my,
my,
my heart back up to that level of output.
Cause it right now it's not there
and I can't just get on a treadmill.
It's boring.
I'd rather play basketball and he's
someone who's going to make it fun,
make it interesting and bright.
And then also,
you know,
keep me from eating fucking Lorna Doones
at like two 30 and does the valve,
does the valve function like normal car?
Except for like 2025
pounds that he don't like.
I'm healthy as an ox.
Right.
Oh,
okay.
So you could do anything.
So if I got there,
you know what you should do man,
he should take martial arts,
take a martial law,
was doing Jujitsu and stuff and then it's
like I kind of put this weight on when
my doctor mind,
I won't blame my daughters,
we had this like a lot of her
life is pumping calories into her,
like keeping weight on cystic fibrosis.
Youngsters is important
for their lung development.
So like everything in our
house is extra fat in it.
And for a long time I just Anna and hey,
I mean I won't lie.
The department,
you know,
you go through depressions and
you know your food is an outlet.
You've got snack a little
too much sometimes.
But food is yummy.
It's delicious.
The problems so good.
But you know,
so you know,
I just wound up putting on weight.
What was the question there?
When I went into my second and my
daughter and it's a whole nothing we just
talking to about what?
Martial arts you said.
Oh yeah I was doing Jujitsu.
Yeah.
And then after I put this weight on,
I went,
I tried to go back and it's like with
a spare tire trying to do hip throw.
You got it.
Yeah man.
You know I was like no I got it.
I got to do that.
I got to drop some pounds to get
back just so I can drop some pounds.
It's just treated as like an,
I mean you should probably
get in shape before you do it,
but you could treat it as some
sort of a mental exercise.
Fire Yourself.
There's some torn.
If I make that move I
was telling you about,
you know,
I'll probably,
I'll be able to hit the Runyon canyon
run and walks and stuff like that.
That's always fun.
I liked that walk.
It's getting up to the top is a reward.
It's huge.
I actually used to pull up and start at
the top and walked down cause then you
got to come back up and get your car.
You know what I mean?
Caffeine and Jack Daniels
also helps with weight loss.
If you throw up a lung Caner,
this was amazing.
It was just terrible for weight loss.
That's horrible.
It's just sugar.
Yeah it is.
Unfortunately because of I drink whiskey,
it turns right into sugar.
How weird.
I'm not hastily.
I can't give that up.
I need to guy who's going to show me
how I can work around some of the feet.
I think that it's,
it's all about moderation,
you know?
I don't think you have
to give up the whiskey.
I think if you want to stay.
Another thing is I stay steady.
I don't,
I I like,
I don't pass a certain point.
You know what I like to 60
and it's like oh that's the,
that's it.
That's too big.
Then you get mad.
I get mad but I never,
I don't go like to like to 90 or 300 I
did once I think like two 90 way back.
Like,
wow.
But a lot of it too is like we
were talking about thyroid earlier.
I,
after my surgery I have to take
a thyroid pill to like keep my,
my,
my metabolism just kinda just went when
all the surgery and stuff happened,
my body just kind of said
we're going to slow life down.
Yeah.
I would imagine that heart surgery.
So I just need to find out
how I can build back up.
I don't even need to do 90
x like full blast like that,
but I didn't know what I'm saying.
But it's good because it makes you do it.
Yeah.
If you're going to eat it,
it seems like it's too much then,
then you know,
do as much as you can
and then stop button.
Yeah.
But it makes you do it.
Whatever.
You're going to find the dude that's
going to take money to help me.
I'm sure
he could find it.
You guys going show up
at my door and be like,
Yo dude,
get out of bed pussy.
You want someone bad like that.
That was going to be your willpower.
Then we'll,
you know,
we'll be fighting and he's probably
going to be in much better shape for me.
So I'm going to have to break out a bat
and it's like an assault charge and I
got to buy him a car
when I should have just,
I got in shape,
get Richard Simmons banding,
smoke a bunch of and have
Richard Simmons help you out.
That sounds like the best thing ever.
You won't feel threatened by him.
You would get to make your heart grow.
Cause he's so heartwarming.
I think you just created the
greatest reality show ever.
Wow.
The greatest reality show as I might even,
I might even say yeah to that
if that's all it was about [inaudible]
I don't think he would ever would bust a
move.
Come on now it's time's gone.
You know,
maybe when he was younger maybe it
would have felt it and felt confident.
Just give you a gentle patter.
The ass.
Every Saturday he does a class in La
that you could actually sign up for.
So I'm sure he's up for,
I'll go grab me some dolphin shorts,
man.
That's right.
Get in there,
son.
Don't be scared to tease.
Don't be scared to give them
a little tease and you know,
like coke and fucking and,
and,
and Sushi and I don't
mean Coca Cola by the way.
Oh,
I know.
I like steak and cheese subs.
Yeah,
I'd love steak,
steak and cheese.
So,
so good.
Steak and cheese sub
with a good Italian roll.
Oh,
sweet.
Jesus.
I know it's bad.
Where are you getting that from?
All sorts of different places
got hooked me out with,
do you ever go to Kava?
Gretta's you want to get some,
some serious Italian food that
you really should never be eaten?
Cavarretta retinas and uh,
I guess it's in Canoga Park.
It's an old school Italian Deli.
God Damn Dude,
they got a sausage and peppers.
It's um,
I don't remember.
I know how to get there,
but it's one of those things where you
take a left on there and go right on
there.
And,
um,
Cavarretta is Google it people.
I'll be there.
This is the news of Michael Douglas.
A throat cancer affect your pussy.
Eating at all is a little shocking.
A little shocking,
you know,
I mean,
cause I could swear I
heard it a long time ago.
Like he first blamed it all on
that kind of already suspected it.
Maybe.
Maybe,
but I heard about just yesterday,
I was first time I heard,
I just heard it yesterday and
we're talking about in a while ago
on something.
Hmm.
Maybe.
Maybe it's just that the,
maybe the media,
you know,
it's picking up on it.
The second run around,
you know,
maybe you talked about it before,
but it's a recent thing because,
uh,
a lot of people think that it apparently
that it was like cigarettes or alcohol.
He sat HPV and his throat.
Right.
Brian don't do that.
That's just rude.
What was that?
Put a Photoshop of them.
Let's face off photo
shopped Michael Douglas.
Plus he works on his face.
That's just rude.
That's is that already is,
but yes,
that's the chief claim.
Yeah,
that's,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of fucked up that
sex can give you diseases.
Like what a stupid,
shitty little fucking trick by nature
that sex eating pussy can give you some
horrible throat cancer.
Well rude and what sex is
most chicks isn't like HPV.
Something like most girls have or most
guys have huge percent of the population
has it.
Apparently they can
just recently they can,
um,
they can give you a vaccination fraud,
but the vaccinations
apparently are a little scary,
aren't they?
Just there for the girls,
right.
Young girls get stacks and there was
somewhere where it's a controversial with
her trying to make the girls like
somebody was trying to make girls get them
like or make it mandatory.
Ooh,
wow,
that's crazy.
And then they give you a
inoculations vaccinations for kids.
They,
one of them to give you is a hepatitis B,
which is a,
I think mostly that's actually
transmittable I think.
And you've given it to like kids,
you know,
it's like how many people get
hepatitis B and now it's like,
a lot of them are just from sex.
You know,
like maybe it's something that the
kid needs to worry about eventually,
but when it,
but when it's a baby,
are we sure that hepatitis,
I just remember being
told when I was young,
sex without love was unhealthy.
Really.
Who told you that crazy ass
hole doesn't want to have fun?
I can't remember.
Crazy.
Fuck my mother.
Oh silly mom.
It can be both.
Sex with love is best know sex without
love is pretty fucking good sex.
It's nothing wrong with it.
People,
if not it needs to be the same.
But the connection,
there's a connection there.
Yeah.
If you know,
if you love somebody,
probably care enough and more about
them to find out whether or not,
but,
but at certain numbers it's like the sex
without the love is more than a rushed
state.
Right.
Let's just go,
come on.
You know,
I don't care.
They don't speak English.
Do you remember when everybody
was worried about AIDS?
I do.
You know what?
I was just saying something
about it the other day,
like weird.
Like you know,
it's nobody worries about it.
Oh,
show wasn't I just telling you other day,
like in the nineties like when you're
out of that five days when you had to
wait,
even if you knew you were cool,
you were like five days.
You are.
We had to wait for the test to come back.
You were still
hold on or this and you know,
dude,
that's no joke.
It's like not even in this
kind of thinks about it.
I remember I was in my car and I was
driving to the gym and I was listening to
the radio and Nace I've remembered the
fucking the street I was turning on when
they said Magic Johnson just announced
that he's HIV positive was home.
I was thinking this shit
was the Zombie apocalypse.
I was like him going on the radio
and saying he's HIV positive.
Oh my God.
Magic Johnson,
one of the greatest basketball
players of all time.
We're all going to die.
I was like,
he's got hates.
Holy Shit.
It's common man.
I would,
I just anticipated a wave of AIDS.
He said never arrived.
Change.
Strange.
Strange,
strange.
I remember when he died
of aids and I was like,
wow,
cause that one,
nobody even knew about
it until he was dead.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And these people that are
dying of AIDS in Africa.
That's a really fascinating
thing as well because,
um,
apparently someone please tweet me,
and correct me if this is incorrect,
but
what I've was told was that a lot of
what they see when they release figures,
like,
you know,
x amount of people have aids,
that doesn't mean x amount of
people or even HIV positive.
That means that they have
the symptoms of aids.
It means their immune system is fucked.
So they see these people in,
whether it's from poor nutrition
or a host of various diseases,
they don't necessarily test every one of
these people because it's expensive to
do that.
So apparently when you hear
x amount of people have aids,
that's a little on the rough side.
It's a little bit of a rough estimate.
What,
you know,
it's just people are fucked.
It's a shit spot to be,
there's a lot wrong with being there.
There's a lot of fucking diseases.
It's not just a,
you know,
HIV like,
Goddamn Africa's got a
host of fucking diseases,
especially when you're poor
and you're not eating anything.
And then like I remember seeing something
on a show once about like there was
some certain tribe or area of Africa
where the believe the cure for aids,
what's to fucking version,
which is like,
wow,
oh,
how do you even come up with that?
Africa is still rock,
some really crazy ways of life.
It gives you insight into the way the
world was just a thousand years ago or
2000 years ago.
Like witchcraft is huge in Africa,
which craft and burning people because
they're witches and accusing people of
witches and people doing things to
help cure you of demonic possession.
There's like a big business in it where
they like cure children of demonic
possession and they,
they,
they take them from their
parents and their required,
their parents come up with thousands and
thousands of dollars to give to them.
So the parents go fucking crazy and do
anything they can to get the money to get
their children back because this guy's
claiming that this child is possessed by
the devil.
So if he doesn't do this exorcism,
like they'll kill this kid like this.
It's a a normal common thing in Africa.
I remember seeing something
about that fucking crazy.
There's a,
and there's a ton of them and they're all
running this racket scare the fuck out
of everybody killing people and it's,
it's an,
it's a naughty place to live
and it's 2013 man.
Just like,
you know,
we're sitting here chilling in the valley,
having ourselves a good
old time drinking coffee,
kicking back,
playing music.
This is dude out there is like burning
people because he says there are a,
which you know that's
all going on somewhere.
Yeah,
it's nutty.
It's Nutty as fuck or moving there.
Don't go to African
people tried.
There was a bunch of Europeans are
going to start a wildlife preserve.
I think it's going to
preserve itself just fine.
I don't know if you really
need to preserve it,
you need to stop people from killing them.
People where people are always
killing him for like hard on pills,
you know,
it's always Chinese people that think
that you can get some Rhino Horn grinds it
up and you dick grows some tiger penis.
That's ridiculous.
That's what,
that's what,
what else?
There's some other benefits for Rhino
Horn or other uses that they use,
but that's what they're
killing these rhinos for it.
They're like wiping out the white vinyl
population and because people in Asia
have this thing for rhino horns,
it's kind of,
it would kind of suck if
there was no more rhinos.
Rhinos are kind of bad ass.
The fact that that thing actually,
there's gotta be thin
at this point though.
It must be very thin.
I think some of them are actually extinct
now because these dudes just won't
stop hunting them.
They don't give a fuck.
It's just this is,
they live wild.
That's a wild place.
We're so,
so off on that same thing.
I loved cater hunters,
man.
I love all people.
I want to go,
yeah,
I want to go.
I want to go with some pros.
I don't want to go and
just try and kind of gator.
I want to be one of the themes
and like just even being,
the boat's got to be an adrenaline.
I'd like 12 foot gate or on a boat.
Fuck
those dudes got to be
strong as fucking oxys.
The one family,
the son and the dad,
they'll their bill young dudes
with that crazy accident.
The Dad's got a rat tail that it was like
supposedly like the world champion arm
wrestler in his weight class.
I believe it.
I bet that guy's drunk as fuck.
He's a son,
supposedly fights a little in me,
man.
That's Ron dinosaurs around all day.
I mean the literally pick it up
dinosaurs and shoot him in the head.
In the original season of swamp people,
there was a dude that
would go out and live,
catch them for like experience
like scientists wanted to go.
You've got the medium sized ones but
still water by their necks and he would be
like,
tape.
Wow,
crazy.
Love that shit.
How do you get good at that?
Those are the people that are going to
be around when it all goes bad still.
You know that right?
Well if you want to go to Louisiana,
you can be around too.
They're everywhere.
Those fucking,
you can't kill the alligators
enough like there's,
you have to really go on an assault.
Those guys are pulling 500 out of season.
They still got,
yeah,
he's still got alligators
all over the place.
Crossing highways and shit.
They're disgusting.
That must be rough and a dog around there.
Fuck yeah it is.
I,
when I lived in Florida,
dog got stolen from some old lady.
That alligator just
go rack doggy every right to that.
His mind,
their gallery that's not stolen as the
rules of the word dog was slipping.
Not only is it Doug slip
and it was tied to a chain.
There was an old lady who can't run
other end and that's just dinner.
Yeah.
The Florida one of the alligator
recognizes the old lady couldn't run.
I wonder because it just
came out of the water.
It's like,
Yep,
I'll take that Mac.
Cause she's lucky it took the dog.
She's very lucky,
but they're weird.
They're,
they'd very rarely attack people.
Although there was a story recently
where a guy was running from the cops.
It was on a,
in Miami and he,
uh,
hit the brakes and jumped off an
overpass into the water right where an
alligator was.
So literally as he jumped into the water,
the alligator attacked him and killed
him right in front of the cops.
Probably got jumps off a
fucking bridge and lands on you.
The alligator just fucked him up.
The cop said it was like
a scene in the movie.
It's like the guy literally
locks up his brakes,
jumps into the water,
and then it's,
ah,
alligators are just ripping them apart.
But other than that,
it's pretty rare that they get people
crazy crocodiles with what we've got to
worry about.
They have a,
they found Nile crocodiles
and the everglades now.
Yeah,
that's scary.
So they,
they,
they issue to kill on order
for these Nile crocodiles.
As far as they know,
they don't have a breeding population,
but there definitely have been
spotted in the everglades,
which is fucking real problem assholes,
Florida,
the fucking cock of the country that are,
that place is crazy.
Phil would nutty white people who are
on bath salts and the fucking throwing
snakes out their car window when
they're driving down the street.
Then they're assholes.
Florida is filled with the redneck.
He has redneck assholes on the planet.
It's a lot of fun down there though.
It's on another level from the deep south.
You know,
it's like the deep south.
That's like the Mexico of the deep south.
That's what Florida's like cause
it's like you go below the deep,
deep south is all class.
He and shit.
You can go to Tennessee
and be a gentleman,
have a bourbon and you
know what I'm saying?
But you get down to Florida
and shit gets crazy be.
Why?
Because it's the Mexico of the south.
That's what it is.
It's like,
man,
it's barely America.
When you're in Florida,
go do gigs in Miami.
Dude,
you are barely in America.
And I say that in a good way.
Like it is a beautiful energy.
Like they're fun.
Fucking peep on that.
So one of the best places to go if you
want to just go and unwind and have a
good time.
I love watching all those,
uh,
you know,
cocaine,
cowboys documentaries about how
like basically Miami has just built,
built out of cocaine real and murder.
That's,
I mean literally built.
That's like literally built the city.
Yeah.
That dude,
Billy Corbin.
I met him in uh,
in Florida.
He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Those documentaries,
God damn good cocaine
cowboys won the two Giselda.
Is that what her name was?
Just tell the blonde girl Roselda Zelda.
Ooh.
She was scary.
Did you ever see the gun?
Don't second cocaine
cowboys where it's dude was
dude was banging her was
like making it happen.
The Oakland guy was like,
shit,
Billy's man,
it's hilarious.
He was just,
he stroked out there to get his little
stick way at every time he got to jail.
And then how about the fact she got out?
That should be by action.
You're going to get at do some
you got to get at do some salute,
man.
He for him.
Fuck yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is a strong mills.
You couldn't take a pill and just go
in where he had to get that shit up for
grizzled.
Yeah.
That is a strong move.
Are we sure that it was before
there was Viagara when was fired?
I was like in the eighties man.
It was,
it was it the eighties hmm.
I'm pretty sure this was in the
eighties early nineties at demos.
When did they invent Viagara?
Brian Know Brian at his home.
The weather was [inaudible] 78 degrees.
Those core,
those commercials are always so lame.
It's always like a couple with gray hair
and they're holding hands and they look
at each other and they come
close and you know the cuddle,
you know it's,
it's never a dude with a maniacal look
on his face and a boner that's five hours
old will not die and he's
sweating and his heart,
it's fucking Liba Navis
chest.
It's never that.
I'm always curious about the one that
says it lasts for three days and you can
just like kind of call
upon it when you want.
Jeannie,
you keep for three days.
I'm on that shit right now and it sucks
it really the three day things not that
good like it.
All right.
Explain to me how that works,
what you can just summon a
boner while you were on it.
I noticed like the first
day it's like just intense,
like everything that
happens close to your Dick,
it just makes a boner immediately.
Like today it's more like if I
start touching it or if something,
if Jamie starts like kissing
it with is pretty lips,
then it would definitely
like shoot right back up.
But it's not as sensitive to the point
where I'm like walking around like
Goddammit,
I have a boner right now where
the first day he is third day.
It's just kind of like you
have to try a little harder.
But when it's ready,
if you take invite Viagra
or Cialis or which,
which one of them was,
this was black power,
which is,
oh,
it's probably see the Alice,
but it's a bigger pill so it's
more Cialis than a normal pill.
So it's like five days worth of Seattle.
Oh my God.
Why are you taking all of that?
Because I have,
but I don't you
be a better idea.
Don't think it'd be better.
I did just take like half a pill.
Have you ever thought
about taking half a pill?
No.
Cause I do you think are you going to die?
Oh,
where are your heart's
going to fucking give out?
I think boner pills at a
certain level or unhealthy.
Well,
it's weight loss problems other places.
Most of the time
it's like it's hard to
borrow it temporarily,
but the interest rates get higher
the longer you hold onto it.
Check Danielson's Ferris,
so he says
biological lunch,
there's no bug free book,
biological,
free lunch.
When you take something and it has a
very positive reaction and also probably
has some side effects that you're not
really aware of that are equally powerful.
Yeah,
ripping pussy apart.
[inaudible] another thing it does,
it really helps.
It's not coming at all.
That's like if you sometimes don't
even come and you're just like,
all right,
I just fucking made that chick have
like the best sex and the whole entire
world.
I know many people across the country
or a barfing right now I'm just thinking
of you having sex with anyone and you're
talking about Taryn pussy apart and put
a quilt quilt done.
After that they hurt your brain or
brain already heard which one is,
that's crazy talk.
No,
it's cool.
You should probably have less.
I think there's,
there's a certain dangerous with it but
you know that's one thing that is weird.
Apparently it didn't enhance
his athletic performance.
It's banned in the Olympics
cause it's three cycles.
Your,
your blood positive
doctor Brian,
how would you a scientifically described
the effects of it moves the blood she's
down around or your place.
Yeah,
but apparently enhances endurance.
I like how the pill was called
the black power black power.
It's a,
it's a white guy.
Fucking a black chick on the cover.
Okay.
Right.
Got It.
Cause I was like damn,
he's making that grow happy.
Yeah.
Skinny white guy is only get white
girlfriend or only get black girlfriends.
You know those dudes,
the white dudes are only Jewish guy.
Tell a lot.
We take those things man.
I got,
you know,
with the heart stuff.
But I remember,
I remember when I got out of hospital,
a really important thing to me was the
doctor said you can't have sex so you
could walk a flight of stairs.
Wow.
And I would look at the stairs
like every day and be like,
I'm gonna try it.
Three steps.
And I'd come back down to,
we bought a week and a half.
Now when they date,
they give you open heart surgery or
they have them open up your chest bone?
Yes sir.
What does that like,
how long does it take
before that heals up?
Um,
do you feel it now,
like when you touch it,
does it bother you?
Sometimes I feel the
wire through the skin.
Yeah.
Cause they wire it shut.
You know what I mean?
There's a little wire in and
when I get x ray you see like,
it looks like a little Barb wire
thing wrapped around the sternum.
Does that go off when you go
through the metal detectors?
Man,
they'd have,
they have to have it once or twice
in my life since this happened.
I believed that,
that it's that set it off.
But it's like when they're on super high,
like if they're set high,
I think I've got,
I've gone through those,
you know the full body,
they never say a word.
They never asked me about anything.
I don't even know if they see the full
body is a radio wave thing and what it's
looking for is external objects.
Right.
Looking for shit that you might
have in your pocket and like shanks,
you know sometimes like those lines,
those make it go off if it,
if it's set re you know,
ridiculously high.
Wow.
Like I've had guys go like what is that?
And I'd be like,
I won.
I didn't wear a necklace to the,
I was like you must be getting
either the wire or my valve.
Wow.
Right through the skin.
How fucked up is that?
We have to test people from metal,
make sure they're not bring
anything hard on them.
Does it feel foreign?
Like sometimes there's like
vibrate during certain things.
Like if you're like on a roller coaster,
do you feel like I just certain
foreign object inside of you?
No,
no,
no.
It's all the,
you know,
the crazy part is like acoustics of rooms.
Sometimes if I'm sitting
in the right spot,
it's so loud.
It's ridiculous because it's like tick,
tick,
tick.
Yeah.
Like people,
I'll be like,
what the hell?
You know,
if I'm in the right
spot in the right room,
that is why,
because 90% of the time for me,
it's white noise.
You know,
I to just kind of,
I don't hear that anymore.
I want to,
I can hear it click his life.
Yeah.
Oddly enough is it,
you know,
it's,
it's a clock.
To me it's like,
all right,
that's,
that's each one of those is the second
I was thinking about it the other day,
I was just talking to somebody about like,
you know,
when you really figured out what,
how many days we live?
Maybe thirty five thousand
forty thousand days.
Is that a lot?
365 days a year.
So ten seven hundred 3000 so you know,
23,000 if you live 60 years,
70 years,
call it 70 70 times 365
sounds like we were all math retards.
It's a lot of time and
somewhere in that neighborhood.
Right?
I'm sure a lot of days 40
let's call it 50,000 days.
Your life is right.
Does that sound like a lot doesn't to me?
No.
It doesn't sound,
I equate it to dollars,
man.
I could spend that now.
I go to here right now I spent $50,000.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I hear you.
I wouldn't want to,
that would suck,
you know?
But unless you're a gambling man,
you know,
or just an ass.
Yeah.
I think we like to think that the
shit is going to last forever,
but clearly it's not.
Yeah,
it's really short,
man.
That's the one thing that whole thing
really made me realize when I was laying
on the thing going in thinking I was,
I was literacy mainly thinking I was,
I wasn't coming out of it.
I was like,
I'm dying.
Do you know the whole,
for me,
I didn't see visions of
flashing before my eyes.
It was just the whole,
I think I might even said
it on the show before.
It was the summation of like,
that's how long it was.
Right.
That was a blink of a fucking
I from birth till now.
Right.
Which is,
wow.
And that was,
you know,
and that's really my
biggest lesson out of it.
And now I've got a clock ticking.
I'm the,
I'm the crocodile from Peter Pan,
you know?
Well,
when you go through anything that really
makes you think that it could be over
there,
makes you reassess the whole picture.
Sometimes we just get real used to
everything used to be and you know,
I build to go to the
supermarket and get food.
You get used to being able to
get up in the morning and walk,
you know,
you get used to all being alive.
Being alive.
Yeah.
Just the,
just being conscious.
I mean,
the world is a strange,
strange fuck place manner,
which is so used to it.
We don't even think about a stranger does.
Every once in a while I'll sit back and
just think about the actual breath I'm
going to take.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
What that,
what we just and what you took in,
what your body took out of it,
what you're pushing out.
You know what I mean?
That one simple thing is,
is,
is high science and it's
invisible completely.
You need it and it's invisible.
You don't even know where it is.
It'd be in a room,
there's none of it in there.
And they walk in there and God.
Whoa.
What,
what led you to,
to,
to the Muslim religion as opposed to
like Christian with a family that,
um,
was,
was Muslim.
They never once talked
to me about or anything.
I found some literature that I've read
and listened to a tape or two and at the
F my fundamental understanding
of it is it's actually all,
it's all three of the Judeo Christianity,
you know,
it's that whole,
it's a summation of all three is it?
Yeah.
What are the,
what are the three,
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam.
It goes through all those so
called profits and all that.
And to be honest,
it's like all those,
you know,
the more the older I get,
the more I see.
Those are stories I still,
like I said,
believe in the creator.
I believe,
see Islam for me just brought me like,
oh,
this is all connected.
And it was like very much about peace
in a time in my life when I needed that.
And,
um,
but like I said,
like I,
I have not part of any mosque.
I'm not part of any and I haven't even,
I don't even practice like that.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
for me,
it's like personal.
Again,
if it wasn't me and you
having this discussion,
it's like,
man,
it's not,
it's not even important,
right?
It's my thing.
Whatever,
yours is yours.
Right.
Cause if I was a real Muslim,
like hardcore,
everybody,
it's praise Odin,
I'd be all offense.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that would be a great use of it.
And it's just,
and it's so silly because it's,
it's like,
come on,
we're,
that's kind of the point,
you know what I mean?
And,
and I,
that's when religion for me
gets narrow minded and just,
I can't,
I can't follow that path.
So what you say is that
you benefit from it,
you felt you find benefit from the
knowledge I've taken from it and I don't,
I'll never,
I mean you could say I'm Christian and
Islam and Muslim because I've practiced
both in my life.
You were talking earlier
about Catholicism.
I have,
I was raised like in going to catechism
school and all that and learning the
lessons.
And then at 14 I had the,
uh,
what they call it,
confirmation,
which was you go before the bishop and
you basically do this thing and you can,
you're,
it's like you're sort of Bar
Mitzvah of a Christian and Annette,
that symbolic way.
We didn't get any checks or big parties.
Um,
you know,
it wasn't a big of like that.
It was just kind of,
you go there and you're a man now and
you get the Holy Spirit is supposed to
come down in you.
And I was buying in at that age,
you know,
I mean I bought in,
I was going to it all and I remember
sitting there and the church and the guy
anoints you with the thing and you say
the words and I'm walking back and I sit
down in my pew and I'm like,
okay,
it's going to have another,
kids are kind of act,
act not.
It wasn't like,
ah,
this happened to me.
Book kids were like happy in the Aa and
I just didn't feel it goddamn thing.
And for me it wasn't that I
thought religion was bullshit.
Like how you turned.
That was for me it was like,
Oh man,
there's something wrong with me.
Oh for a long time.
You know what I mean?
And then like I said,
I found this other thing that
Kinda was accepted me on my own,
on my own terms.
I,
nobody introduced me to Islam personally.
Nobody said this is what you should think
or believe or here's something for you
to read.
This stuff fell into
my lap and I was like,
like I said,
I follow signs and so that
got me through a very,
I believe like that philosophy and
the way it took my mind are one of the
reasons I'm still alive today.
I think there's some great,
yeah,
lessons and a lot of organized religion
and some great lessons and in both the
Bible and the Koran and the tour,
this is a great lessons in there.
The problem is they're old as fuck and
they need to be updated like they need.
There's not,
it's not a bad thing to
have something like a Bible,
but it's a bad thing to have some old
shit that nobody truly understands and not
have some just guidelines of
how to live life and be a happy,
healthy person and don't,
you know,
don't necessarily say that they came
from anywhere.
You don't know where the
fuck they can't from.
But these are things that people have
accumulated and we figured out in time
what's up.
I got a song if you got a
song about this religion.
Oh,
okay,
beautiful.
Let's do it.
Isn't my religion.
Okay.
Friday,
it's almost like we set this up.
Well,
that's why I had to grab the guitar.
Powerful.
Everlast that's my religion.
This call Friday the 13th okay.
Oh,
thanks man.
Down with red lights.
Shine wants to junk is foul down the bed.
The Sun rass run out of smashes him.
The drugs they sound clear from over here.
Todd is throw some money on table.
Go from last night's loving
God so loved the hall.
Got My heart of with known to man
fucking things up.
I do the very best that I can.
I'll come.
Y'All got crazy.
We're smiling.
The money and the eye last crazy.
Nobody wants to go to heaven.
Holdup Hoda.
Hoda.
I got mad as dragon.
Hold up.
What got you distracted?
I'm ready to call you
out on taking my head.
I'll listen to that if
you were on the phone.
My bad.
No,
don't let it distract me.
You're fine.
I was worried it was an important call.
No,
I don't turn my phone never
calls me during the blog.
I don't judge.
I'm just saying I lost my
fucking whole train of thought.
So we're going to do
this again from the top.
Okay.
All right.
I wound up on that song.
Sorry.
I get a voicemail.
I got nervous.
I don't blame you.
I,
I live in fear of the,
of course I don't want just like God.
I couldn't even let go of it in my brain.
I had to stop,
start over.
They see everything's fine.
Real relax.
Shai wants to,
John's foul down the bed and wants to
sound rises when out of spasms in the
drugs,
this out to clear middle here,
it's hot as an oven.
Push come to shove and throw
some money on the table.
Cover last time stuff and got the solar.
The whole got the heart of a lone man
fucking thing.
So,
but the best that I can,
just lack of a horse to the wilder.
The walnuts drank it hill and no
one should know the scared little,
but I'm really one hell of man.
And now I'm a junkie.
Fall in love.
It's a Java stranger's hair
ever.
Things love up in the heavens.
But here you must atone for your sams
for charging one lost stock badge,
high bleed again,
still out seeing the singer
sewing machine can be gay cow.
So we get nice
clean and with that
scared to have knowledge.
You Bow,
you got the mind of a leper,
the love and saw Chuck Kane
and it's not breaking down.
And that's true.
Leo Survival.
Cleveland sacrificial
brand new raffle Gurus,
government issue.
Hoffler stone got a
knob that's about taking
the fucking posting up
phones with us going sweet.
My name
cause the owl going around stupid.
The owl got lazy.
It was bowel and Barney in the idolizing.
Crazy.
I didn't want to go to heaven,
but everyone's afraid to die.
God is real.
But religions out.
Just one
boss said lower body.
Somebody's got to smoke.
It said one big you.
Aw Man.
That's your really,
it was horrible.
No,
that was great.
It's horrible.
No.
So it was a real moment,
man.
No,
I let my mind get away
from me on that one.
Listen,
I shouldn't have answered the phone.
I was going to be polite
and leave the room.
You got to do it,
that would be more distraction.
Okay.
All right.
Let's do a,
all right.
We'll do this.
Lawrence pound.
Sam,
not long ago,
last Slu,
Lazo Stern and justice to people
were behaving like they are good.
A little ball wasn't
misled by none little ball.
This is what he's saying.
Me and you,
God,
we're going to make some cash.
Rabid new foods.
Then Megan a dash,
the deer.
The Jab,
money came.
Ease wrap,
boom.
Had a disease.
He wrapping up.
Amnon was sister and a brother,
Chad rapper man was DT on the cover.
The cap grant is on stopping Dagney.
Radicchio keep still bold.
There's no need for static.
Almost a man as a gay Muslim.
Linda didn't know little ball.
A strap pulled out his card,
so why you hit me?
Bill headed straight for the cow.
Kidney cap gets scared.
His styles to finger do
is if I pull this trigger.
So good Dass Dick van around black
cow radios in with another lady.
Cow Ran by treaty,
resolved since the chapel.
The head shot back,
but he messed up.
Lou rounded from Max big tits and he
decided he'd hit full the subway station,
but she was coming.
So when may left,
he was right on.
Speed was out of breath,
knocked the no man down.
Swelly killed him the meters.
Lou Duane abandoned
building ran upstairs to,
that's how I flow Wooten up the door.
And guess what it saw Dave,
the dope fiend shooting dope.
Don't know the meaning of water.
No soup.
He said,
I need,
let's hurry.
Young duping brought back the
spank and shy went outside.
There was Casal Luke's who
dipped to car wasn't stolen.
Brock,
do you need three?
Crashed into extreme.
He University Scape [inaudible]
Senate Ratatat tatted,
no cat scan went out of Berlin,
but it's still has static.
Ran a brain and then it
blew down your own man.
[inaudible]
Hanson come through later,
told the cops back off or hunting
his dead deep in his heart.
He knew it was wrong,
so it let to let it go
and he starts to move on.
Sirens sounded,
seem to sit down and found out
the little ball got surrounded.
The dropped his gun.
So when this is where
it got to in this story,
he was only 19 and man man's dream,
I hope pantsuit kid is still hear him
scream the same funders don't you Dan lab.
Just another case about the round bat
straight and now who your soul gets cas.
Good night show.
Oh yeah.
That was beautiful.
That reminded me of the
Trayvon Martin case.
Man.
There's a lot of that in there.
What's was going on with that didn't
have just in the trial is about to start
again.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on with that.
I think it's,
it's heated up.
It's in the news all the time.
It's,
it's fascinating the case man.
People are in real trouble
for manipulating the news.
The way they,
uh,
they portrayed it.
A lot of people were under the impression
that that was like a little kid.
There was like really small and those
were like really old pictures of him.
You know,
he's a much larger kid and they,
he beat the fuck out of that
guy before the guy shot him,
he had blood all over his head.
His nose is punched in.
There's a lot of weird
shit as to whether or not,
you know he was a victim or he was an
asshole and that he shouldn't have been
doing in the first place.
It's good.
It's a very racially divisive issue,
you know?
It's really fucked up issue.
He's alive though.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
You could take a punch in the nose.
You can apologize for that.
You can.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what man,
if he thought that dude was going to
kill it right or wrong and I'm outside,
I'm just saying like one dude's alive,
one dude's dead and one dude was
following another dude when he have been.
I had,
apparently that's not true.
Apparently a,
that was something that was also reported.
That wasn't true.
He didn't,
they didn't follow that kid.
Apparently they told him to stop and he
got in his car and the kid was looking
for him.
But who the fuck knows?
You know when,
when something like that happens?
I never heard that,
but I don't.
I'm in a bunch.
Bunch of different versions of something.
World problems.
Yeah.
None of them are from,
but that song reminded me of that a lot.
You know?
Slick Rick Song.
Children's story.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
that's right.
Once upon a time.
How long ago was Amazon guys?
All this learning and jobs.
That's the,
you know Andy?
Wow.
It's so different.
I didn't even recognize it.
That's the front of my brain to shake
off that because I hate when I screw up
or,
or just getting a little something.
Yeah,
I know.
I can have the best set ever,
but I fuck up one joke and that
shit will haunt me for days.
That's why I had to do
another one right away.
I sit here looking at you like,
wow,
that was fucking awesome.
Don't worry about it,
man.
It doesn't Peter.
People don't think that it comes out
right every time people know that's,
that's,
that's the beauty of the does.
I'm worried about people.
Joe Rogan people have been
nothing but good to me.
I'm just saying,
me personally,
personally,
right
there.
Nobody else understand that.
Accept you right now.
You know,
other people like it's no big deal,
man.
It's no big deal.
Still all awesome.
That's a beautiful song,
man.
That religion songs,
beautiful song.
A lot of people that's
going to be the anthem.
It's just me saying like I said,
what if God is real?
And then legends all just a big lie,
you know?
Well,
you know,
that's Kinda how I look at it.
Like God might be real man.
You know what I mean?
I kind of feel like it is whatever it is.
I think it's,
it's beneficial or not going
to be pleased with them.
Motherfuckers murdering
each other over the rules.
I think it's beneficial.
There's one rule that we all,
we all know it,
right?
Do one to others.
That's the rule that it really is.
That's the only rule.
I think it's beneficial to be humbled
by religion actually is the last line in
that song.
Somebody needs to spark
it and being fired.
That's a real religion.
Everything he says,
it's not a religion has
never taken a pot cooking,
gotten on an airplane.
That's a real religion.
That's real.
It's real.
It's,
it's,
it's humbling and makes you
think about your childhood.
It makes you think about
love and happiness.
It makes you think about honesty and
friendship and makes you think about
creativity.
That's real man.
That's theirs,
that's connecting you
with a spirit of nature.
It made you paranoid.
Yes,
it made you feel weird,
made you have all these crazy thoughts
cause it's connecting you to the spirit
of nature,
the mother Earth Gaia in a
little baby dose of a plant love.
And that baby dose of plant love just
sparks every cannabinoid receptor in your
fucking monkey brain.
And you start seeing shit in a way that
you're not going to see without the weed
like it or not.
But if you're a man of your own creation,
absolutely you have gotten you where
you got because of hard work and
dedication.
So true,
so true.
But you know what?
You will have an experience with that.
Marijuana spirit gets
into your bloodstream.
It gets in your system and gives you
a little dance and you can accept
the fact that you were tuned into
some other form of intelligence.
You could accept the fact that there's
something about this thing that's making
ideas explode inside of your
brain and never been there before.
Or you can just fucking
keep drinking coffee,
go to work and just
believe in stupid shit.
Been working right.
Oh it is.
Double Rock did the this is
there a better voice voice one.
The silver one is better
so it gives you a very specific sound.
Oh,
here's this one.
Here's this one compressed.
Oh,
okay.
Pretty low compression.
No Mike Better.
It'll make for a better audio on this
thing and you could call me up and do
dirty talk to me and I
wouldn't even know it was.
Yeah,
I'd get scared.
That's not what I want to hear.
Kettlebell workouts.
I'm doing battle ropes today,
brother.
Today's battle rope day.
What do you got now?
Man,
we'll do another one.
I can shake off that bullshit.
Oh you son of a bit
still still.
It's still,
no,
it's gone.
I apologize with all my heart.
I did not think that that was
kind of distract you dude.
I've done it to every interview ever
cause I won't turn off my phone,
God forbid in case on it.
And it wasn't a judgment.
It was just like I just couldn't,
I had the cords in my hand,
started playing another song and
then lyrics from another song.
It's like some weird,
I've never written anything down.
So it's like if a,
if a picture gets cross referenced it,
I,
I'm fucked.
That is such a fascinating
way to do your music.
I know Jay Dee Dee,
Jay z does his raps that way too.
I think that's really fascinating.
I mean for me it's,
again I think we discussed it but it's
like it started as like a wrap thing.
Having a hall right here,
I don't need it.
Well you probably should,
you know,
I mean there's probably some benefit
to having it all right there.
You know,
be able to pull out at anytime you want
instead of relying on pieces of paper
and you record it all.
And like I said,
when I open my eyes and saw something and,
and then your brains,
you know,
automatically is asking questions.
So,
you know what I mean?
It's not even,
it's just like,
that's not even like fuck Joe.
It's like what's going on?
Something bad happening and
that's enough that the songs gone.
It's like,
I think it's cool for people to just get
my fucking eyes closed is what I should
did.
That's what I,
that's why I closed my eyes a lot during
performances cause it's sometimes some
mother fucker will turn around
and like do his Facebook photo,
shoot a Selfie with me in the background,
like in the middle of a con like fuck,
come on.
Right.
We used to go to concerts
to listen to watch concerts.
Right now they're like watching it through
their phone for their youtube post.
Yeah.
They're looking at their life through
a little four inch window instead of
living.
If it's distracting and calming shows.
You see a lot of that.
A lot of people holding their phones up.
You know,
on one hand it's nice you
want to take a picture of me.
But on the other hand it's kind of weird.
It's,
it's what's called weakness.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] name was Lucy Cadillac,
this monkey.
So now
I got a weakness
top down afternoon.
She made me cry,
limit deep.
And Matt asked,
grandma died when she was
five and she didn't know.
She seen
you will hurt deep in my bones.
I got a weakness out of
the sitting on the edge.
She's saying I slept with gangsters,
thugs,
smuggler,
Congress smelling govern,
missing golden man.
But this weakness is,
it's Matt
starts to
sell map.
Yes.
My scan and
I got a weakness.
You
know
I
got a weakness.
I have beaver,
I got
edge.
Just Wayne.
Yeah.
And you paint with a dark brush.
Don't,
don't.
Yeah.
Almost always.
I mean there's happiness in it,
but you pay with,
oh yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's the bad.
This whole little bit.
All the interesting people do that.
Unfortunately.
I hate giving people the impression
that you have to make sad music though.
Cause I mean I,
it's just not what I do.
When you are happy music,
not,
I can't write that song,
jump around.
You know what I mean?
You know,
that's just a whole different
different time to write for you.
Do you hear like that old stuff like the,
the,
the rap stuff and go like,
wow,
that's like a different time.
Yeah.
My voice and I know I'm just a baby.
I haven't even had,
I didn't even find my voice until
like the third house of Payne record.
It's weird isn't it?
When you look back on all the shit that
you've done and it took me like three
albums to find my singing voice.
You know what I mean?
Like Whitey Ford isn't,
when I find a singing,
it's good work,
but it's not my best.
Like thank God nobody talked you
out of putting out that record.
Tell that story.
Cause Tom,
hey,
they tried.
That is so frustrating to me because
it's always the case where people just,
for whatever reason,
they,
they don't ever want
to accept that a dude.
Like you could do more than
one different kind of thing,
you know?
Yeah.
I hear that man.
Um,
I just,
again,
I follow the signs.
I just Kinda of go back.
I got,
I got to the point in house pain where
I felt like I was showing up for the
checks and that made me
feel rather core link.
It must be hard to do things
with a bunch of dudes,
even if you love him too,
even if you love him.
Just to throw one.
Writing songs with a bunch of
other dudes seems like a nightmare.
Well,
musically I was doing more
than my share of the work,
so I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Again,
it just became not fun.
That's really what it was.
It just do.
It became a point where,
and luckily I'm spoiled rotten
enough in my life that isn't,
it wasn't fun.
I wasn't doing it.
Yeah.
And I didn't care.
You know.
And the thing was I wasn't Uber
rich when I quit house of pain.
I was,
I hadn't,
I had a few bucks,
but like it was going to be like,
what's next?
Like in life,
what's the next day is I didn't know if
I was going to make another record at
all.
You know,
a friend called to come to New York,
fuck record deals.
Fuck labels,
just getting a studio and smoke some dope.
See what happens.
He heard me playing guitar in his living
room one night and we got record that
and this turns into that and what
it's like is this and then you know,
still I don't,
none of it is like was sup like
mapped out in some superior plan.
We didn't have,
you know,
it was all going by your install on
the best shit the Hams is by accident.
Of course.
Yeah.
There was a,
there's a very few songs that are
guaranteed to give me goosebumps.
But that song that you
did with Carlos Santana,
the key,
turn your lights on.
You want to eat?
Fuck yeah.
That's one of my all time favorite songs,
dude,
that song.
But before you even pick up a guitar,
there's some about that
song where you know,
when a dude saying
something where there's a,
there's an authentic pain being
expressed as an authentic emotion.
Every word is like
every word is qualified.
You know what I mean by an experience.
And there's a,
there's something that comes out of
that and that saw everything from Carlos
Santana's mother fucking
guitar that 60 years of,
you know,
bullshit that guy's gone
through in his life,
60 plus years to all the shit you were
going through when you wrote those,
those lyrics and the way
you were singing him.
It was,
that's a,
that's a fucking crispy song,
man.
That song.
Whoo,
that's,
it's crispy.
Like you hear that song and just whoo.
We get those goosebumps.
Selena meant to be things.
You know what I mean?
Cause I definitely,
I had done that.
We had discussed this in detail.
I'd finished or the house or the Whitey
Ford record and got out of surgery and
was being leaving a house
and got fucked over.
Yeah.
A lot of things happen at the same time.
We're account and fuck me in in the
hospital because cause the account,
fuck me,
I canceled my insurance cause
I didn't have insurance.
I had a hospital bill at like 400 grand.
I went from overnight being like,
like I said,
a few bucks.
You know what I mean?
I had like cash,
maybe like half a milli or something.
You know you need people right now,
but wait a minute,
this is what the fuck was depressed.
He had half a million dollars
one day the day before.
Oh.
Then the next day I owed the government
like fucking after they took all the
bread,
like I still owed like the
government in hospitals,
like half a million.
So you went a million
dollar swing in like a day,
let's call it a week.
Oh my God.
You hear in the news
about getting screwed.
But then I had this song and somebody
says Santana's looking for a song and sent
it and we talked about the rest man.
But it was the first song
he cut for that album.
He called it the centerpiece of his wreck.
I'm proud of that.
Give me a call,
man.
I ain't heard from you in like 15 years.
Carlos.
Carlos Santana does not listen to his
podcast and somebody that knows him desert
busy being 1500 times
or by the time everybody listens
to that old Carlos Santana,
he was speaking to this.
I found a rock on the beach yesterday.
I was with my kids and we found this
rock and how there's holes in it.
And I said,
is I like from space?
Like is that an asteroid or a
media right or something like that.
Like what is this?
And so I put on Twitter,
I said,
does anybody know any
geology people out there?
Know what this is Joe Perry from Aero
Smith because the first person to respond
and he says it's,
it's a c,
it's like a type of sea rock.
And uh,
it's a,
it's come from the holes
come from water erosion.
I was like,
God damn re the real joke.
And he's the first person,
the first person that responds,
I'll add Twitter.
That's where this t game and tag is nuts.
Joe Perry is a cool motherfucker.
I've,
I've had conversations with them.
Carol Smith,
dude,
one of the bads guitars of all time.
Maybe Joe Joe Perry's
baddest lick of all time.
So many of them too.
Not just that one.
I mean,
that's old school Aerosmith.
That's worldwide,
that's darkest corner of Africa bar.
You put that on somebody in
that bars and be like Aerosmith.
Oh yeah.
I grew up in Boston,
so Aerosmith has royalty there.
Boston royalty.
They came from Boston,
you know.
Oh that early shit,
you know,
walk this way.
It was tremendous,
tremendous fuel those
guys had behind them.
But then eventually it became
ballads and he's not only,
but the shocking thing is
not that he follows you.
To me,
it's that he's a goddamn gem.
Ologist or whatever.
Well I think he's a part of that
whole rock for science thing.
Is that what it's called?
What is it?
Hold on,
let me find out if that's true.
There's something going on,
Brock.
The science,
some,
uh,
maybe this will be a,
somebody can hold up to,
I dunno.
There's something going on.
Rockets.
I Dunno.
I think there's a,
I shouldn't have said that because
I don't know the information.
See if you can Google that.
Anybody.
Brian,
see if you could pull up,
cause it's going to take too much,
too much look.
But I think there's a,
the Rock Stars of science.
Maybe that's it.
Yeah.
Rock Stars of Science.
And they're,
what they're trying to do is get
kids to be excited about science.
So you've got people like
they're following Joe Perry
following rock stars.
So many junior high and elementary school
kicked are falling.
Any rock stars nowadays,
right?
They're all like
little Wayne would be,
you know,
on that.
And you might get them kids
deeper little Wayne right now.
Joe Perry's just got,
you know me and you going like,
Damn.
Yeah,
it's Joe Perry.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of people in here
and then a bunch of science people.
This is interesting.
So it's actually a show.
What is that?
It's not rock stars and science.
What was Andy do frame in,
in,
in that movie he liked to shape the rocks.
And what did they call that tall?
It is,
I don't know.
It didn't sound like Jamal
and just as someone who,
uh,
like his studies rocks,
right?
Just all rock geologists though.
That's geologists,
gem ologists like someone to study jams.
Those Jews in the diamond business,
that movie,
the Shawshank Redemption,
they're moving,
they called him something in that,
that diamonds are like very pretty.
There's no mistaking that,
but man,
what an amazing job they've done
in making diamonds like this.
A valuable commodity.
Storing them in a warehouse
and releasing them.
One that you keep in the prices elevated.
That's a meme,
right?
Their diamonds are very pretty
well,
they are Brian.
Okay.
That's why people are
willing to pay money for him,
but it's fashioned.
Keeps so many Australian market.
Yeah,
it's brilliant.
The way they're done is brilliant.
You can,
isn't it kind of modeled after the
gas industry hasn't of just the work.
I mean,
I take it that's almost the same
principle sort of all these countries.
We have so much in reserve,
but yet,
you know what I mean?
It's the cast is necessary.
Diamonds that serves.
There you go.
That's it.
That's much more gangster talk people
into buying a shiny rock for no fucking
reason.
It's marginally talks people into it,
but it's like you have to buy it
for the woman you love half tablet.
The genius.
She was like,
it's part of society now.
Like that's you're expected to buy a
diamond ring for an engagement or wedding
or whatever.
I mean that's expected.
You cast your Dalry he can't
be coming home with no rubies.
No,
that's your dowery and it has
to be like three months salary.
Yeah.
What's so good fucking assholes.
That's an asshole slogan.
Be honest though.
I wish I had only spent three minutes.
Where were you then?
It's a slogan,
man.
It's like have it your way at Burger King.
You know,
they're just selling shitty cheeseburgers,
you know,
don't,
don't try to make it is,
my wife has an official
one engagement ring.
When I flew I flew her to Paris.
Just kinda like,
I decided it was like,
no,
it's time Paris.
Yeah,
I was on tour.
Oh well I flew her like out to Europe.
We hit Amsterdam and few other places,
but I,
my plan was Paris midnight,
Eiffel Tower movie style.
That's bad ass.
But like I knew I had a
jewelry guy here at home.
I'm sure you know who he is.
Dana put me onto him.
Okay.
So he was,
he's like,
I got you.
So when you get back.
But I was like,
I gotta do this.
So I went into a little London,
a jewelry store and bought like,
you know,
$500 little sliver diamond ring and you
know my wife treasures that just as much
as the other one because that's
when I gave her at the thing
I did.
I'm like,
Yo,
like you would have
saved me a lot of bread.
Well I think they like
both but it's a weird,
this one is special because this one came,
this one is,
no,
that makes this one special.
Right.
It's a weird thing that people are willing
to spend so much money on some little
tiny piece of rock.
It doesn't really do anything
was that was very strange.
It was coal.
Yeah.
Long time ago.
It was a thing in wired magazine years
back where there was a guy who was using
Russian technology and he was creating
diamonds and the significant ones like up
to two and three carrots I think.
And they were also making
different color ones,
which are really rare,
but they were able to,
I was just going to say I
have an old like 20 year old,
like I have a canary yellow
diamond pinky ring and it's like,
it was really,
it's really Rick because it's natural,
but nowadays it's like
you can get them like,
I mean that's why all these guys
have like rainbow fluorescent,
like diamond.
Well that's all fake anyways.
90% of that shit.
Right.
But here's what's fascinating.
I have a great idea for a show,
Joe.
Okay.
It's gotta be somebody
that can fight though.
Richard Simmons,
I'm serious.
Like,
yes,
I can do a diamonds,
red carpet.
Fucking somebody on the red carpet at all
these advanced and like all these cats
that
wear this ridiculous jewelry.
Primarily wrappers.
A diamond tester.
Oh,
that would be so rude.
That'd be so rude.
No,
you'd be blown.
People's spots.
It got to do it.
It's ridiculous,
man.
There's guys walking around that that
got like apartment complexes around their
neck if they're real.
And those dudes,
if they're real,
I got guys that want to get at him.
How rude that is.
Not Very Islam have you sir.
That is not very nice guys.
They weren't sure who they are,
where they are.
This is what's fucked up about the
machine that makes the diamonds.
I've talked to several women
who said this exact same thing.
They say that those diamonds wouldn't
be as valuable to them because they came
from a machine that they want the kind
that comes from the ground and I'm like,
even if it's just perfectly exactly,
exactly duplicated.
It is a diamond.
Like the only way you can tell
that this diamond and this is,
this is a fact,
like this is not a disputed thing.
The only way you could tell,
because if they tell you like they've
taken these diamonds to gem ologists,
people work in the diamond trade,
the DeBeers group,
and they've looked at them and they
cannot distinguish these from perfect
diamonds.
Like they can make a perfect diamond.
So it's a real weird thing.
But for women,
that's why we walk will lie to women.
It's a real weird thing.
But for women,
that thing is that the one that's
more valuable is the one they want.
They want the one that costs more.
That's what I'm telling you.
It's the actually want
it to be worth more.
They want some sort of twisted revenge
on the fact that original marriage was
basically an exchange of pop property
or a property for wife property to,
you know,
become the daughter property
because why property?
What are you giving me?
I think they do it for girls as
much as they do it for themselves.
I think they do it to show other girls
to have big as bowling ball on their
finger.
Look what he got me.
That's how I got my plus as,
okay,
I'm looking at here.
You got me.
Exactly.
You know,
and want to let you know they rock.
Some mother fucker
brought them in a boulder,
you know,
and it's like,
well this is like a little competition.
Like who did better,
you know?
Well,
I mean to the same degree
as we all want hot wives.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
We all want a nice car.
You also,
yeah,
but you want to fuck hot wife in
it before she's the wife of course.
And then you buy or like an SUV or
something to cars I like or not.
I don't like,
I'm comfortable cars.
I like cars that are stupid.
My wife does not like any of my cars.
I like to drive my car,
my Nice,
my fun,
my toy toy car,
that dope Audi spaceship thing.
That's,
sorry.
That's one of the most
beautiful cars ever created.
That Audi r eight masterpiece.
A masterpiece.
And like if you were a kid like back in
the 1980s and shit and you look back at
the future like what's a car guy looked
like in the two thousands that Audi,
is it man,
that's a fucking spaceship.
A four wheel drive spaceship
with paddle shifters.
It's fun.
It's a dope car,
man.
You got some,
you got some stuff?
Yeah,
my favorite car.
I've got a Porsche gt three gt three Rs.
This the stupid car.
Nobody should be able to buy that.
You shouldn't be able to buy something
like that and just drive it around.
It's a race car.
It's ridiculous,
but it's,
you're so connected.
You know what?
I'm a really been getting into man though
recently really been getting into old
cars.
Like when I look at like there's something
to me like I went for a long time.
I didn't dig old cars because of my,
I had a bad experience with a car.
I had belt at a 1970 barracuda built.
Right?
But there's some about like old cars,
like if you get,
get them to run and drive them around,
there's so much more satisfying.
If you could actually get a 1969 Camaro
and drive that motherfucker around,
you could actually get it to the point
where you could actually drive it,
make sure that it stops
when you want it to,
and make sure that blinkers
work and all that bullshit.
If you could like get it
shipped down to that point,
you're in a,
you're on a goddamn time machine.
You're driving around in a a working
piece of art that sounds like fun,
like a giant Dick roaring
as it goes down the street.
Everyone old car I want to build,
but I haven't found the right one yet.
Uh,
59 El Camino.
Ooh.
I haven't found the right situation when
I've come across them and people would
want too much for him.
It'd be in like Iowa.
Right.
That's a beautiful car.
It's another car.
It's a Goddamn you're,
you're in a different time
when you're in that car.
The first El Camino
skirts on the back wheels.
Oh yeah,
I'd do it.
Kind of like 1500 is a good year or two.
But interesting year,
you know those,
those cars of the early fifties or the,
the late fifties and
early sixties so I didn't,
amazing times man.
Like the old Barracuda,
it doesn't have the
best shape in the world,
but man,
it's got a weird shape
representative of a strange time,
you know,
in 1968 big ass.
Huge fucking muscle cars.
Yeah.
Slide all over the place
with shitty steering.
Like your car.
That car is like intimately
connected to every move.
The steering wheel.
Yeah.
And it's bought it or I went and picked
up my homie and we were just going
around like the residential
neighborhood and I was like,
watch this.
And I was doing like 50
and just dead made a right.
And there's,
you know,
there's a button you press on there like
where the shocks fill up with fluid.
So yeah,
it's just,
it's crazy man.
Well let's see.
Got a,
an almost perfect 50,
50 weight balance cause
that's a mid engine car.
That means the engine is
behind you and your seat.
It was a brilliant piece of engineering,
man.
I was told it's the
poor man's Lamborghini.
No,
that's silly.
It's a better car.
It's more,
it's better looking.
Lamborghini looks like you're on coke
if you drive it around a Lamborghini.
Honestly,
between you and me,
like I couldn't spend,
when I went to buy that car,
I went to a spot here in Pasadena where
there's a bunch of car dealerships,
you know,
high end portion,
all this stuff.
And I went there and I
went looking for an eight,
actually just a sedan cause I was,
it's another beautiful,
I've been driving.
Um,
basically Sam series beamers for years.
Like I was,
you know,
and I just wanted to switch it
up and I heard that was the same
or similar and then the class and I was a,
so I went and saw it and
the salesman told me,
don't you don't,
I told him why I like beamers and oil.
I've been driving them for
so long and he was like,
you don't want this car once he,
I was like,
that's exactly what I said to him.
what do you mean?
He's like,
Nah,
this is just saying,
he's like,
this is a great fucking car.
And then I realized,
I think he knows who I am and he's like,
ah,
you know,
you don't want this car.
It was like,
and I'm waiting,
I'm waiting for the pitch.
Like,
okay,
what car do I want then and it,
and it doesn't come.
And he's like,
Nah,
this is just this.
I was like,
well,
what are we?
I was like,
all right,
well cool.
I'm going to go next door and look at it.
Another car,
you know?
And it was like,
there was a Bentley
dealership right there.
And I went in there and saw that Bentley
coupe and it was like this thing,
it was $250,000.
It's like,
I feel like a jerk off in this car.
Right?
I mean like driving,
it's just,
I'd feel like an extreme jerk.
And I went into the Jag and they'll,
new jag wasn't out yet.
Like I might at that
Jag would have been out,
I might have bought,
I might've got that
just because I was like,
well,
you know,
and I was just in one of the car that day.
I had a truck,
I got to think I've got
to have a car in a truck.
That's my thing.
You know,
there was sometimes more than that,
but I got to have a car in a truck.
So we'll first world problems,
first world problems.
Right.
So then I,
you know,
I didn't see that.
So I'm walking back to get
to my car where I parked,
I have to go back through
the Audi showroom and then
I see the r eight and the
corner and it's white.
And I go there and looking
at them and reading.
The guy in the kid comes
over and he's like,
having,
this is bad ass.
I was like,
gas stove.
He starts talking to me about it and I'm,
and I'm like,
just kinda national outlet,
you know,
in my brain saying,
I can't get this fucking car man.
You know,
why are we thinking that?
Just because it was like,
you know when them
things like that's a win,
you know this,
it wasn't practical at all.
There was nothing practical about it.
There was no back seat for kids.
There was no,
no.
I was like,
nobody's going for this.
My accountant's not going
to go for this today.
They're going to break my balls over it.
But then I'm like,
ah,
it was white.
So it's like,
I hate white cars,
man.
I hate him.
And he goes,
I got a black on black
carbon fiber one in the bag.
And he was,
I don't even think he
thought I was looking.
He was just like,
you want to see it?
I was like,
sure,
I'll come see it and I see it.
And it's you,
you'd see my car at the time of the day.
Was it?
When you saw like four,
oh that's even right up where the sun
is just slowly starting to make its way
across.
This carbon fiber was just
popping in and out and I was like,
oh my God,
if you could have
the car looked like a sneaker
to me and I'm a sneaker freak.
So I was like,
oh my God,
that looks like it's just something,
it reminded me of an Air Jordan somehow.
That's so hilarious.
And then so I'm like,
Yo,
I was like,
let me take it first payment.
And they were like,
Nah,
we don't do that.
We'll take you for a ride.
And he takes me out for some reason.
This is what they told me they were like,
unless they know that it's basically sold,
like in,
they like,
you know,
looking at you like you're buying this
car and I had no inkling yet of buying
the car.
What you should do,
just sit down in the purchase seat,
take a CD out,
put in,
jump around and point to and go.
That's me.
I didn't have to do that.
Just let me throw this out in car and
we'd go down and it's back there by the
Rose Bowl where it's all canyon and
we get like three blocks from the
dealership.
He pulls over and he
gets out and he's like,
get in,
drive the motherfucking car.
Smartest the kid ever did in his lap.
That is a good move.
He was fucking,
the bosses didn't know shit about me or
anything and I'm tattooed to the kills
and like I didn't even have jewels.
I would look like kind of like I look,
I can help kind of bummy that.
I didn't even have jewels to
be walking around with tools.
Man.
I got my,
I didn't have my jewels on.
You know what I mean?
Maybe it's a good sales move by him to
pretend they won't let you take it away
and then get outside of town and get,
I'm going to get gangster cause I
know you're a bad mother fucker.
Take these keys man or
anyone to tell his boss.
Either one of them like go ahead drive it.
Smartest thing he ever did.
Right.
I pulled it back into the dealership
buying this right now,
this is my car.
All right.
And then I'm like,
all right,
let me,
let me show the Wifi and I'm sure
the WAC and he's going to be like,
oh,
what are you doing?
And the kids can't sit in that.
I text her,
I think I'm going to buy this car and
just sending a picture of it and I'm
waiting and I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
Was somebody going to come talk sense
to me right now not to buy this car?
You know,
I wasn't sure.
Is this a midlife crisis?
I was never really a big
sports car guy was a big sign,
like a nice sedan,
like old man kind of thing,
you know?
And then my wife sends
back to the first Texas,
you deserve it baby.
I was like,
dude,
I got to buy this color.
That's why I wound up with my toy.
Maybe been one of the most
heartwarming podcast we've ever done.
Brian.
That's because of his heart
inside your pussy tearing stories.
Besides that,
everything else is not how this,
this functioning.
Uh,
you know,
you can just call upon
that whenever you want.
The boner pill works.
Having a card like that
is like driving a ride.
You're in a ride every day and you don't
even have to abuse the law like this.
People don't understand just
turning corners at normal speed.
It's like you're so connected to it.
It's fun and you don't even have to be
a nun on the freeway and you get nice is
a lot quicker because you
can just dart in between.
There's,
the control is so amazing on those cars.
You know what I mean?
You can do things that I would
call other people assholes for.
That's when we made engine
four wheel drive car.
That's a crazy car man.
That's brilliant.
Piece of [inaudible] sport mode
and put those shock absorbers,
fill him up with the fluid
and that car is on rails.
Man.
That's said crazy thing
about those old cars too,
is that they do a lot
of adjusting for you.
If you fuck up,
like there's traction control that comes
in and stability control and antilock
brakes,
like do it.
They do a lot of correcting for you,
like to make it much more safe to drive.
The cars were thinking driving.
But that's the thing
that bothers me though.
I love that.
But the thing that bothers me
is that you miss out on like,
there's like a feel when you drive in a
steering wheel that doesn't have power
steering and you know,
you're,
you're hitting breaks that you,
you feel the brakes lock up.
You know,
it's like you have a more
of a connection to a car.
Those old cars,
you know,
it's not good.
It's terrible if you want to be safe.
But as far as like real,
I like the Audi.
I like driving it and driving it
fast because every once in a while,
even though it's that smooth
and cool and everything,
you're so low,
you feel every bump.
And then also every once in a while
you'd do something wild enough to,
it makes you realize you
gotta be scared a little bit.
Women,
women will never understand.
And dudes who have never driven cars
like that would never understand either.
That's one of those things
you talk to people in,
they're like,
I don't give a fuck about cars man.
You say that,
but I don't even understand
what you're saying.
Like you either haven't driven one
of those fucking things or you don't.
You can't afford it so you
don't even want to fuck with it.
Which I understood only ridden in them.
They've never done it.
You know,
they've never drove a car.
Sure.
If somebody just came up to you and said,
do you want this?
You'd be like,
fuck yeah,
and then you drive anything like,
Oh man,
this thing is awesome.
You would get it then.
But this first world problems,
she didn't drive this.
He knew.
He knew the minute I put my foot on that
thing and so the corner I was going to
be like,
I'm going,
this is cars going home with me.
If anything is,
I remember a guy came up and was like,
I want to look at this.
I was like,
get away from my car.
I like before the paperwork.
That's funny.
We get away from my car,
man,
that's my car.
He's sitting in it and farting and I
wasn't having none of that can't be,
that's a,
that's an impulse buy
that you could pull off.
You've got damn Everlast.
But if you're a dude who's living in
an apartment and you drive one of those
things,
you're an asshole.
Had a good look.
You gotta be real careful
about things like that.
Cause he's just like financing.
It just makes it so tempting.
It's almost doable.
If I just work a couple
extra shifts washing,
washing dishes or whatever the fuck
I'm going to do and slinging drinks,
I can just maybe get that corvette.
It was 150 and it was still like Ooh yeah,
made me go.
It's real money.
I mean like you know a lambo or isn't
and that's like two fifties you know what
I mean?
300 I think it's a way better looking car.
I like the Audi better.
I honestly do it.
It's not what never again,
the reason I started talking with us,
I would never,
I mean one that is about my limit
where I would spend on a car.
I wouldn't say it's not understated
cause it's a pretty audacious car,
but it's classy.
It's beautiful.
It's like it's designed well.
I'm iron man,
dude.
Come on.
That's what I'm talking about.
Shit,
I'm driving.
Right.
That's the one thing still to like it.
That car is like three years old now.
The body sits.
That's a great thing is this device dot.
I ain't going nowhere right
now and but like kids still.
Yeah,
like they,
they just light up when you drive by
some kids they're like iron man car.
Yeah.
Some people don't get it.
It's a thing that a,
first of all,
they get upset that you're talking
about some shit they could never afford.
Sometimes people get upset about that.
They be these two bridge to talking
about buying 150,000 because you fucking
kidding me.
It's the last thing people want to hear.
Oh well but oh well
I'm 43 fucking years old,
man.
I've worked 20 fucking years of my life,
I pay mortgages.
Many of them.
I hear you man.
Some of them don't even belong
to family members of mine.
Man.
I can not.
I can by myself.
That's what my wife taught me.
That's you deserve that.
That's beautiful.
You earned it.
Yeah,
go get that.
I'm a self indulgent motherfucker.
Yeah.
I I believe in true of what we do.
I believe it's important to be
a little self indulgent debate.
I was told by a good friend when
I first like kind of made it like,
and I was stressed about this,
that and the other and like every once
in a while go out and buy yourself
something,
whether it's a pair of
sneakers or something,
he'd just go out and you'll,
you'll feel bad.
This is a certain amount of
management you have to do.
Your impulse was,
but I think it's important to be impulsive
on a certain level is important to
just go with your instincts on shit,
whether it's with people or
with or with business decisions
or with writing material
or writing skills.
For my kids,
man,
I would live to the edge Joe.
I'd live to like a penny
in the bank and then,
cause I've check always comes like it's
eventually I got a good thing going on
man.
Is jump around,
man,
that thing don't go away,
man.
Check.
Like I could live like a pretty,
I think I've been here so many times
and we talked for so many hours.
I don't know what I've said to you or not,
but like I could be that huge debt.
Uh,
w what's the dude who got
caught with the hooker and in,
in Hollywood grant,
he grant you Greg.
He had a character in a movie that lived
off the money of his dad's song and I
that could be that guy so you can live
the rest of my life and not do a fucking
thing.
Wow.
I mean,
so I was that guy until I have kids now.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I got to put some of this away.
So,
but I mean,
I would trick money off Joe,
like money,
money,
walking the bars by a bar.
Not the whole bar,
but you know,
any by the bar for the night.
Like how much did you make tonight?
Three grand.
Everybody's drinking for you.
Here's five,
you know,
stupid shit.
I remember one nine Hollywood fucking,
when I was real young first came back to
la with like a big stack of money in my
pocket,
went to this club and this bartender chick
was just ignoring the shit out of me.
It was a packed night but I was just like,
I was like,
no,
fuck,
this bitch just really ignored me like
five times two I pulled out just a stack
of hundreds and I started
crumbling them up,
just throwing a matter of
throwing them out and like,
and then she realized there was like $700
on the floor and it came over and the
next thing I know I'm,
I'm,
I'm running the bar.
That's hilarious though that throwing
money at her just as long as the number
was high enough folding it up and she
was like hitting her with it and she
accepted that because it
was a hundred dollar bills,
you can't do that shit with toys.
She got very upset that she was getting
something thrown at her and then like
she went and picked it up and was like
he'd it and like it was like fucking,
this is,
these are hundred dollar bills.
This sounds like a movie in the 1980s
and you would wind up sleeping with her
that night and then she would regret it
because you were in a band and you were
in a Boston.
Yeah.
Runs right into throwing
hundreds of her face.
Yeah.
I've,
I've bought,
bought a bar before,
but the whole bar around the drinks,
I used to kick everybody.
When I kick anybody out
of the comedy store,
I'd buy the whole audience
around the tracks.
I S oh,
they still love doing that because
the comedy store never had any,
um,
there's no one watches the crowd.
Like if you go to a legitimate comedy
club and people start mouth and off,
the security guy will
come over and tell him,
look,
you're going to have to leave
you disrupting the performance.
The company store,
there's no security.
I used to go there all the time.
The dog on Monday nights.
We used to go there and just get nuts,
but yeah.
Well what is the open,
Mike night is a Sunday.
No,
Sunday and Monday.
Yeah.
There was a night where it
was like if you went in there,
you'd see a bunch of shit comics,
but you are guaranteed
almost that some large cat.
We'd walk in and do something like,
it was like Monday I was at like a tree.
It was like,
this is like almost 15 yeah,
back there.
I think it's still probably like that.
Murphy might pop in and
do a set or you know,
last week I was Mike Tyson.
It's like every week
it's somebody like the week before that
we Chapelle and Mike Tyson is actually
doing stand up there.
Yeah.
It just crazy.
You imagine that one of the fucking
car story you see Mike Tyson doing was,
I want to see somebody heckle a,
that's what I don't think
they're going to ask.
What I want to say.
Are you taking it?
We
did.
You see in the jackasses when they
let that butter bean dude punch him.
Oh
man,
that guy's going off.
But I wanted like to talk to him
about how badly that fucked him up.
He never been in no,
no.
I don't know me here
cause I loved that I'd be,
I'd be listening to that multiple times.
Butter bean tee off on him like,
oh,
like his dick.
Literally that was after
he was a movie star.
Yeah.
After he's moved,
we started,
puts a fucking blind fold on.
Let's in there with a bullet.
It's the scenes over and he's like,
is this okay though?
He's crazy.
Those guys are ridiculous.
But that butterbeans shit was,
he just stood in front about her being
my bottom have been just chaos him.
Yeah.
There's another one where the,
uh,
one of the party boy guy gets punched
by by PR guy recognized it was an MMA
fighter.
Yeah,
I remember that one.
Did he actually like tried to have an MMA
fight with a real guy from England and
he fought it.
The shit out of Schick whipped
the shit out of him too.
Oh Donna,
I think done.
Done right.
Done.
Fought him right.
Died in the car accident or a man.
Yeah.
Those guys are nuts.
Guys are living on the edge man,
you know?
Yeah.
But we get and dude's punch
you in the head like that.
That is no Bueno.
I bet you all them dudes.
I mean it's sad.
Is that Ryan done thing
is I wonder if he gave if,
if,
if like in the scheme
of the story of life,
if that's the better death or if you
would have made it to 90 and been boring
and decrepit or cause they live that life,
you know what I mean?
As much as they get paid to do that shit.
There was a time when they weren't right.
I think one of the
first things either Bam,
I think it was Knoxville,
didn't he shoot himself with a 44 magnum,
we put a belt bulletproof vest
on and somebody shoot him,
shoot him.
So he,
I think he wound up doing it.
I'm pretty sure like,
and that was for like Rainer nit mag
when the Internet wasn't anything.
That's a silly bitch.
So you know those guys
live for that charge,
that rush.
Well,
the problem is he killed
somebody over them.
It must be nuts.
And why I would think it should
be a more explored topic is uh,
uh,
Rodeo clowns.
Those dudes who like fucking
stop it levels the chase him.
Like,
like what kind of nut
do you have to beat her?
Be that guy.
That's a hard living man.
That's a hard way to pay your bills.
You let it can be about the money.
No,
no,
it can't be about the money.
It's gotta be about the
money and the thrill.
The bull.
That's unless,
I mean you're not,
so people were saying
about this tornado thing,
you know,
sometimes people,
they say stupid shit when it comes to,
uh,
why do people live in these tornado areas?
They can't fucking leave.
They don't have any money.
You know,
people are born and really
pouring and lived there.
Yeah.
They barely get by.
And for the most part,
everyone they know is there.
Like it ain't that easy to just move.
But,
but it costs fucking money,
man.
And a lot of people,
once you get a job when the big
one hits here and it's like,
wow,
how could you live there knowing
that was going to eventually come.
But my point is,
once you've got a job as a rodeo clown,
that's how you pay your fucking bills.
That's how you pay your fucking bills,
man.
It's hard to jump off
that Rodeo clown thing.
Where are you getting,
you know,
1500 a week or whatever the
fuck those guys are getting.
And then tried to get a job where you
get 400 a week and then you miss that
other 900 bucks.
Absolutely.
In the yard.
You know,
by the way,
that gt three is what
done killed himself in,
yeah.
So yeah.
Yeah.
He went around a turn and like missing
the exit went straight into the woods.
You know,
he was going ridiculously fast drunk.
Yeah.
That's the part of this amazing.
I wouldn't never,
my one,
that's my,
hey gimme gimme gimme a cab.
Yeah,
I got it.
I got a couple of hundred bucks.
And when you live in going
all the way across town,
there was no caps.
He was out in the woods who's
out in the woods of Pennsylvania.
Crazy Fox.
If you,
uh,
you really think about it,
it's amazing.
There's not more crashes because alcohol's
everywhere and people are driving
everywhere.
It's amazing.
Something like on real sports or something
like that where they like went and
like really filmed and checked out a
football game and like how fucked up they
are before and after going like that.
The cops don't really do much.
They just let all these people,
like thousands of people leave those
football games inebriated driving their
cars.
That's a great point.
I never even thought about
that because how many,
what is it,
50,000 what does a football stadiums?
50 to 70,000 so 71% of them are drunk.
Yeah,
my God.
Yeah.
Or concerts.
And those people are,
you usually have drugs on top of that,
like acid football in particular.
We didn't say baseball.
If you go to the dodger stadium,
there's not people fucking
in the parking lot.
Fucking raging.
Right.
Barbecuing and having four cases
of beer sitting outside their RV.
You know what I mean?
Football.
It's like a fucking hold.
They get there in the morning,
they barbecue and get their fucking
shit faced before the first quarter even
starts.
How much of footballs gambling?
A lot.
Write a lot.
A lot of why people love it.
It's gambling.
Got It.
What did it like when people in the
Midwest is there like bookies all over the
place?
Is that what it is?
Like secret bookies or they,
they know you,
but there must be,
there's bookies.
I can give you five bucks.
He's right now.
How dare you.
This is a respectable program,
sir.
All right,
let's bookies need to pay the taxes.
That's what I say in my book.
He's do pay their tax.
Why do you a Saint Barts?
Oh,
it's something like that.
That's a lot of those dudes that were,
you know,
they're just starting to allow poker
again in the United States Internet poker.
They're doing it in Nevada and the way
it works is you have to be in Nevada.
When you,
when you get online they have to do
it and actually gamble from Nevada.
But as long as you do it from Nevada,
it's legal,
which is a strange thing,
but you can play poker.
Hundreds of poker sites I hear about
or they're just free sites now.
Well they're either free sites or they're
illegal sites and they were fine for
why,
how could you be illegal and be like,
you know,
cause I would have heard of are all
over the television and stuff like that.
Yeah,
those are the free ones.
Okay.
But some of those guys got
trouble for doing illegal shit
too.
There was some famous
ones that got in trouble,
but the majority of the people
who were involved in it,
when it was making billions of dollars,
they had to flee and they all had to go
to like the Canary Islands and Shit and
the Cayman's and yeah,
the,
you know,
uh,
what's that one?
Not believes but a Costa Rica.
Costa Rica is a lot of
them in Costa Rica too.
And these poor guys,
they're,
I mean they're essentially,
they got the,
they took their business away with law.
People were spending money and people
were gambling and doing what they're
wanting to do with their money.
And these guys were collecting millions.
They're making millions a day.
And then all of a sudden they came
around with a new law that said,
you know what pitches we're not,
we're not happy with you
guys getting rich that easy.
So you know,
you've,
you've leached the profits.
They essentially stop progress.
They stopped the ability
to gamble on the Internet.
Even though it's a sort of
a weird form of progress,
it's still progress in a freedom sets.
It allows you to do with your money,
things that were unavailable before,
whether or not you want
to gambling to be legal.
I want you to be able to do
whatever the fuck you want to do.
I don't want to have any control of your
life cause I don't want you to have any
control of her mind.
So as soon as we allow
people to come in and say,
you can't gamble on the Internet,
like why do you fucking
talking about like,
why?
Why would you tell me what
I can do with my 20 bucks?
Why do you give a fuck?
Why is this even a conversation?
If you need to get some taxes
out of that sanction gambling,
like the lottery should be sanctioned.
It should be sanctioned.
It should all be taxable.
But that's the point.
I was like,
they needed that.
That's what they're doing now.
They're opening it up.
I'm sure they're getting there.
They're rake of that.
Yeah,
and I'm sure the local casinos probably
weren't very happy with it either.
You know the,
the card casinos that were
making a lot of money,
having people come in and play poker,
all of a sudden you can be
naked playing poker at home.
There's a couple right down here
like bell gardens and a few places.
So I'm sure those people
must have lost money.
And there's a,
there has to be some reasons why they
would limit your freedom to gamble.
But the ultimately crazy thing,
it's just free to login
of poker in the last,
let's say eight to 10 years.
It's TV,
TV,
rope people in an amazing,
it's hard.
It's just makes me crazy.
Then it's also TV combined with the the,
that's the new American dream.
That quick,
easy.
Yeah.
Not only buck,
but you're super famous.
Then you win the world series of
poker and you're the fucking man.
You know Mike Goldberg just interviewed
some dude on the last UFC and he was,
he won $18 million in a poker tournament.
Cheese and you're fighting,
nobody makes that much money in a fight.
I mean maybe Floyd Mayweather does,
but that's about it.
As far as like human beings
has an insane amount of money,
$18 million in a fucking poker tournament.
They make real money
because people love it.
If you get enough people that love it
and they're willing to throw their chips
in,
I mean how many people had
to be in that for you to win?
I mean that's very expensive.
People tournament or something.
I think it's an expensive by until,
cause those guys are worth so much money.
They'll do that by end.
Big World series one.
The big one in the bag is like they get
up to like 8,000 people now starting
those things.
Right.
You know,
we should not Bruce buffer.
Come on and explain all the w Bruce,
I've been meeting the meeting
to get buffer on here.
Anyway.
We'll have him come in here
and explain that shit to us.
Cause Bruce Buffer.
It's like a serious poker player.
Oh is that right?
Yeah,
he's legit.
Like he goes to the world series of poker.
He makes the final table like he's legit.
Bruce spot was one tournaments and shit.
He wins.
You know poker is a tricky
game at Ari Shaffir he,
he used to make a living doing poker when,
when everything's sucked
for him as a comedian.
I remember it like seeing him like
on a few shows with Ari Shaffir when,
when things were sucking
for him as a comedian,
it was making 30 grand
a year playing poker.
Just go into the local casinos winning
tournaments because he's smart because
he's a smart dude and
he can calculate shit.
He knows,
he knows how to play the game and he's
disciplined and it would just make cash
and you've got to be able to keep,
you know,
your,
your face,
you know,
stolen to a certain degree.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's a big deal.
There's a,
there's a something and not giving
it away to any kind of psychological
giveaway,
you know?
That's,
that's what,
that's what I like watching,
like who,
how that stuff works.
Yeah.
I wonder if you get to play all the time,
you can figure out the math is fine.
Most people can learn it.
There's that,
that's where the talent really comes in,
is that whole psychological side.
I mean,
knowing math is talented,
but you know,
what I'm getting at?
Is it more artistic part of it and when,
if you play it all the time,
if you get really good at
just smelling bullshit,
you know,
I mean,
it's like you get good at
everything like you get,
you would think.
Yeah.
You get mean people get better at all
the subtle nuances of anything they
attempt,
whether it's standup comedy
or playing music or anything.
I would imagine that you interact with
people playing the card game for high
stakes for a long period of time.
He probably smell some shit on
people when they are full of shit.
It's just smell a something
little intangible green light
or not or just kid yourself
and blow your fat water.
I mean you would naturally just get
a sense of it of like that movie true
romance where Christopher Walkin's
talking about the tells of a,
you would think you would
at least have more of a no.
What a crinkled Brower like when you know,
cause there's people that say
psychologically like if you're lying,
you look a certain way or if
you're trying to recall something,
you look a different way.
Like your,
the way your brain works.
Like yeah,
you can figure out some of
that stuff legitimately.
And when people know that I
don't trust them from then on,
now you know the moves.
Oh you know it's left to right.
You know?
Yeah.
You cheat motherfucker.
Looking up to your left when you know
you should be looking down to your right,
whichever one that only works if you're
amongst unsuspecting people and you
have,
nobody can have knowledge
that you have that you know.
I think people are,
everybody is scared of losing
privacy and I agree it shouldn't.
Someone shouldn't be able to
access your privacy random,
someone's [inaudible].
You should be able to access your
email or see what's in your computer,
but I do believe that eventually it's
going to be a good thing for the world to
have no privacy.
It sounds stupid,
but I think that a lot of the problems
that we have is that you can get away
with shit.
A lot of the problems that we have
with as far as like committing crimes,
doing bad deeds to people is that
people can't literally read each other's
minds.
I think that's ultimately
where we're going.
I think we're going to be,
there's going to be no line anymore.
I think a lot of people's emotional and
problems stuff is not realizing that
everybody's exactly like you.
Yeah.
You think your thing or whatever's wrong
with you or whatever you think or that
crazy,
whatever.
Everything that happens to you is only
happening to you and you're embarrassed
or you know,
I mean,
there's a lot of things like that that
people don't realize every single what he
has experienced on some
level insecurity band.
You're talking about a one consciousness
almost like single consciousness for
the crazy people,
that's a problem.
Well,
you can eliminate them easier.
You got to,
you got to find them and kill him.
But who's who's willing to make
that call from notify them?
You can notify them,
hand them up,
box them up,
but then they get out and it becomes
a God Damn Stephen King movie.
Yeah,
well you know it's going
somewhere someday is it?
Something's going to happen.
What do you,
if you look at,
I mean you're,
you're a thoughtful guy.
When you look at society and you look
at Shit what's going down in Turkey and
the clamp down on the Internet where the
government's worried about people being
able to rise and,
and the,
the second amendment debates and
all the shit that's going on.
How do you,
how do you see this,
this,
this fucking thing turning out?
When you look at our world?
I don't think a lot of it matters,
man.
You don't think so in a weird,
I just think eventually,
you know what I mean?
Like the lights are
gonna go out and for you,
for everybody,
I'm talking about literally
like not our lives.
I'm talking about sooner or later,
a lot of this is going to go wrong.
We're going to use it.
I don't know how much fuel,
I mean I'm not an expert,
but it fuels gotta be all the fuels
that we use so rapidly right now.
Can't be infinite.
You want to hear something interesting?
I talked to,
uh,
whether scientists,
and uh,
he told me that even if we chopped
down every tree in the world,
we'd still have a couple
of million years of air.
Do you know that?
There's like,
everybody's worried about
like losing all the air.
What are we going to do?
I was like,
you know what I mean?
But the world is far more durable then.
Then we pretend it is.
I'm not talking about
the world or the planet
within it,
you know what I mean?
And our use of like,
you know,
I,
I don't,
again,
I just said I'm no expert,
but like fossil fuels cannot be infinite,
no county.
So eventually,
you know what I mean?
It's not gonna if the lights are going
to go out and we're all going to be
swamped people,
man,
that's funny because I don't think so.
I think that I would've never figured
out how to make you want to know.
Honestly.
That's what I hope I would have never
figured out how to make a regular engine
and I'm never going to figure out how
to make a fucking electric engine and
shoot my gun and I can,
I can reload bullets for sure.
For sure.
There's some people way smarter than me
that are looking at all these problems
and the same sort of genius that allowed
people get to the point where we have
flying metal tubes to take you from New
York to Paris and five hours you did
Howard saying we're going to
have the same kind of shit with,
with everything it would.
People are going to eventually
innovate pass where we're at.
I have a full family from
that because the nine one day,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think it's going to change,
but I don't,
I don't think lights are going to go out.
They might go out for a little
while and then come back on.
I mean at any point in time that could
be a series of colossal disasters,
natural disasters,
and we just look at the history of
the world that we know about for sure.
There's been some,
at least I think there's four or five
extinction events that had been marked
throughout history that we know of right
now and pretend that we know everything
that happened over the four
point whatever billion years
of the Earth's time at this point is,
you know,
that is a lot of shit.
They don't know.
There's 12,002 Asian aliens.
Again,
are we not,
are we going in to the
fact that people been,
you know,
lucky that we made it to this point,
but we could go just bite
the dinosaur wet this.
It's really my point.
Fuck yeah,
but that will another society
eventually rise up and I believe,
yeah.
Okay,
okay.
Whatever.
But like as far as I'm concerned,
like my,
I got my daily problems.
I don't,
I don't the government and the
clamp down in the Internet,
fuck the Internet.
I honestly told,
I've said many,
many times if I could
get rid of one thing,
like I think for every great
thing to Internet's done it.
There's a thousand slimy,
he's coming fucking awful
rotten things about it.
Wow,
that's interesting.
I look at it a completely opposite.
I think for every one.
I mean it changed my house,
you know what I mean?
It did.
I change the trajectory
of a whole business that,
you know,
I depended on to,
man,
I think Dan took the carpet enabled on
delivery on levels that I never would
have imagined in like 1995 it thievery
meaning people illegally downloaded
songs.
Yeah.
Not only that.
Okay.
And then let's just go with the,
you know,
small things like,
back,
you know,
maybe in the 90s if there was
a guy who liked fucking pigs,
you know what I mean?
He'd be alone fucking wolf somewhere that,
you know,
would never really act on it or anything.
Now there's probably,
you could probably find a
website dedicated to that.
Oh,
this is most certainly if people
gather and they fuck pigs,
that's mine.
That's bad for society.
Yeah.
Why is it okay to eat pigs?
But it's not okay to fuck them.
That's what I want to know.
I mean,
I feel like,
I still feel like I love you dude.
Podcast is might be over after that.
I don't feel like,
I don't know if I have any
response to that legitimately.
I don't feel like that makes any sense.
I feel like,
uh,
if you,
you know,
if you will fuck people and we,
and eating them is wrong.
Uh,
well it's not wrong if you're trapped
like car crashed in the Andes mountains
and just eating a person.
Well people have done it.
I mean the whole bond or party,
those people that got
stuck in the Rockies,
people done it and it's a
notoriously fucking like bad story.
Like it's not cool.
It's not like things you
should do on a regular basis.
But I mean fucking pigs,
let's just apply the same,
probably the same logic.
How about you're stuck on an island
and there's no people to fuck,
but you got a think and they
come back after all these years.
The,
hey man,
what were you doing?
Like,
well I raised pigs and a,
and I killed him for food.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
What would you do for sex?
He just beat off a lot.
No,
I just fucked my pigs.
They'd be like,
Whoa,
cool.
Not Cool.
He did something.
Should have just kept that to yourself,
man.
You know?
That's really what it is.
Would it be worse if he
made love to the pig?
I don't think either one is bad.
I think honestly,
if you're going to kill an animal,
fucking it,
as long as you don't
like fuck it to death.
That's kind of a crazy way
to kill something and we
just go anal with the pig or
vagina.
She'd have to see the setup.
You have to see what you deal with,
you know,
condom,
no condom.
It's about a question.
Internal organ lies.
Pigs are supposed to
be very similar to us.
So you don't,
you definitely don't want to go
anal without a little cleanup first.
I mean,
you
get some pig shit through the
tip of your deck for sure.
That can be a problem.
Well,
I'm not sure if I ever,
if this correct,
but it is,
isn't there like a pig's extra excrement?
His,
his,
his entire,
she think her story system
is basically expelling waste.
Like the sweat to a certain
degree is oh really?
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Pigs are disgusting.
They're strange animals,
man.
They're smart as fuck though.
It's one thing that's
weird about killing pigs.
They're smart man.
A smarter than dogs.
They know what's going on.
Oh,
you know the whole animal farm thing,
man.
Well if you still have that book,
I can make a pick squirt.
You ever see that documentary?
A my brother's keeper,
it's documented about
these dudes were like,
they were like a little slow and they
lived on a farm and one of them I think
was accused of murder and it was like
real weird whether or not they could
defend themselves in court,
whether they could,
you know,
there were there a little
mentally challenged,
but they uh,
with running this farm and there's a
scene in the farm where he has to kill a
pig and he pulls out the
shotgun and the pay goes fuck.
And the pig just scrambles left and right.
That pig knows exactly what the fuck
is going on to pick saw the shotgun.
And I saw that and that
kept me from eating,
begging or any pig for
like at least two days.
It was like a month
just silent for a month.
I was like,
Oh man,
I think I'm not,
I'm not going to need
anything that's smart.
Kind of
delicious.
But then I found out what cops,
pigs are you fall into if you like feeding
pigs and you fall in there that eat
you.
That's like number one
way that farm was dying.
One of those Dr. Barton,
the autopsy things where they did this
whole thing on this lady that had a pig
farm and just murder husbands
and throw their butts in the pit.
That was a great show.
That guy was the best that doctor Paten
I lift a love the HPL autopsies show it,
but we bought that.
Challenged your,
your view of the world
before the Internet,
before the Internet.
That was the first freak out show.
Well you realize how crazy people are.
They one dude,
he took a woman and she died.
She was like a very beautiful
woman and she died all,
he made a doll out of her
like put a little rubber,
whole downward her vagina once we could
fuck her covered with like cases and
cases of perfume cause she was rotting
fix parts over with wax and what's he
like a doctor or a doctor.
I remember he was so in love
with her that he took her,
bought his wife wasn't,
I don't remember it was either his
wife or it might've been his ex wife.
I don't remember what it was,
but he took,
it might've been just a patient,
but he took her and he was just
perfect during his Rafkin her body.
You need to know that man.
We need to know that dude's out there.
Yeah,
it's important because you can,
you could have a really distorted view
of the world will know where all those
dudes are.
When that single
consciousness comes around,
it's coming.
We'll all be like,
well don't you think?
Don't you think with what you're
talking about with like you know,
people realizing that you know,
one consciousness realizing that doing
to others as you would have them do to
you,
you lead a healthy,
happy light and y'all were all like
calming down and connecting in this thing.
It all,
it's all building toward this crescendo
and if it reaches that one state where
all of a sudden,
whether it's a technology or whether it's
just the human body evolving to a next
level,
maybe that's a few generations
away and mean who the fuck knows?
But that's what I feel like the one thing
that's going to stop all the bullshit
because when everybody
knows the bullshit stage,
you think we're going to get to that.
I think we're going to get to a
connectivity very similar to the Internet,
but it's going to be in your own brain.
That's what I think.
I think that the connectivity of the
Internet gives you through social media.
I think it's almost like
sticking your finger through.
Like,
you know,
you can't get to the outside but you can
like poke your finger through this like
gelatinous sort of shield
that separates the two worlds.
You can't quite break through,
but it's close.
So the Internet is like,
you're exchanging information,
it's free.
The whole cut into the girl right there.
Same,
similar.
We're using computers in order to,
you know,
we're sending like ones and Zeros
to each other and we're connecting.
But we're doing all this
through this artificial shit.
I think eventually this artificial shit,
this is just a bridge to some
sort of technological freedom.
This is a bridge towards some next step,
whether it's saying
something will be implanted.
We couldn't be,
it could be that I'm going to this,
uh,
you don't have to,
you can just die off like the fucking,
you know,
like all the other,
my nothing wrong with that man.
This is a romantic thing
to that they'd go out,
Johnny Cash style,
all old singing hurt,
you know,
fuck.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I mean,
we all go to sleep.
No,
just I just know the fucking history
of corporations in the world.
And Shit and I'm not letting
anybody putting it in my fucking,
that's the question though.
What?
What does that eliminate all the
bullshit that corporations do when,
when everyone's accountable
for their own actions?
Is that the thing that the manufacturer
or the thing that goes in your brain?
I mean,
maybe it's inevitable progress.
Maybe it's the inevitable progression
of where technology is heading.
So Joe,
you have such a great outlet,
man.
I do occasionally.
I'm way too suspicious of people.
I know that.
I know that the true nature of
a lot of motherfucking people,
that's true,
but don't you know great people as well.
Just the fact that those
beautiful people exist.
I know enough beautiful people,
beautiful personalities,
friendly,
healthy,
happy people.
I know enough of them now to be convinced
that it's not like an aberration.
There's,
there's a whole population of
likeminded happy people out there.
The problem is there's
separated from each other.
That's not necessarily true.
Even the evil people themselves are
surrounded by other either evil people.
That's a big issue with evil people.
You're growing up around evil people.
You respond to your environment,
you imitate your atmosphere,
you're a cunt.
You know,
and sometimes it's not
even your own fault.
You just stuck in a shit
spot with a Douchebag,
dad and a mother who's a fucking
cocaine addict or whatever,
fill in the blank with your
own troubles and dilemmas.
But I think that ultimately there's so
many cool people and so many nice people
and people that want other people to
be happy that I just feel like that's,
that's the trend of where
they live in that world.
Then that's,
that's the world we should all live in.
It's not impossible.
That's the fact that there's so many
of them means it's not impossible.
It's just at point.
Do I have to give up my guns?
You have to give up shit.
Why don't I don't,
that's I'm not giving up.
I don't think you should give up guns.
I think it's ridiculous.
I don't think you should
give up your car either.
I don't think you should give up
your ability to buy lighter fluid.
I don't think he should
give up your ability to,
to buy a fucking helicopter.
I don't think you should limit
your ability to do anything.
I think freedom is the most important
thing and then be responsible for your
actions,
but stop people from doing country
shit by making them aware of one
consciousness,
making them aware that we all are
experiencing this together and if you fuck
with people,
if you send out some bad shit,
that bad shit comes back to you too.
It's,
it's possible.
It's a met so many nice people.
It's just,
it needs to be like when you were talking
about Islam and about the messages of
Islam,
they rang true in your mind and they made
sense to you and you felt like it was
a this conglomeration of wisdom,
so to say.
Right.
I thought of it still does.
Yeah,
and it's still,
it should,
I think that we're just
missing a new version of that.
That's all it is.
It's not that people,
I could feel that and I think
that with technology at the helm,
I think it's possible for
that to influence it as well.
I think the,
the,
the connectivity that we all share
and the inevitable it bill ability to
exchange information
freely without a computer,
without anything,
just connect to people freely.
We could have never pictured this.
No one,
no one in George Washington's
time saw a laptop coming.
I mean there's no way and I think that
we have no fucking idea what's waiting
around the corner in a hundred years.
I don't think we can,
but I think if you look at the,
where it's going,
it's going towards just a full separation.
I speculate closer to 20 and 30 years.
I think.
So no I don't think,
I think what you're saying is going to
happen in there and I'm saying but that's
my,
I don't speculate out farther neck
cause I don't expect to live longer than
that.
You know this part of me that thinks it's
fascinating that like what if society
got like just close to
ignite enlightenment.
Just close like almost there
like breakthrough technology
walls dissolving every
second and then an asteroid.
That's money we have to
start all over again.
That's it brought me right
back to the lights going out.
Well you paint with a dark brush.
My brother,
that's where I came with a dark prod.
That's why I love it.
I like your world.
Yeah,
well my world is your world
that we exist in the same space.
Well I like the window.
You're looking through your world.
I need to get me one.
I think you're doing this podcast
has helped shape that window.
[inaudible] when that window that those
ideas I've always sort of had somewhere
in the back of my mind and then slowly
reinforced by other people that have
meant that shared or and even
more evolved version of that idea.
But doing this podcast,
we're running into so many nice people,
so many cool people,
so many people that are just
genuinely like happy and like,
like if you were my neighbor,
you know that that would
be a beautiful thing.
Like if you are my neighbor and
he was one of my other neighbors,
I would want him like two houses down.
Right?
That motherfucker is a screamer,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like like to have a real
community like that.
If you really look at it like if everybody
was like the f your favorite people,
boy the world would be fucking amazing.
The world would just be a bunch of
people being friendly with each other,
you know,
exchanging things,
doing work,
doing whatever the fuck you,
you have to do,
you pay me for this and I do that for you.
But if everybody was,
if that is kind of be a way where at
least on a mass scale that that can be the
majority of people.
I don't see that.
That's not possible.
I don't think it's inhibited by finances.
I don't think it's inhibited by resources.
I think it's inhibited by
people understanding that
they can live a different
kind of life.
And I think that's where something like
a guy like you talking out about it and
a guy like you expressing your ideas.
Like some kid right now is a big
Everlast fan is in his car and he's,
you know,
listening to this and he's hearing your
take on things and maybe he'll pick up a
book on religion.
Maybe he'll pick up a book on philosophy.
Maybe he'll,
you know,
maybe he'll stop one pattern of thinking
and introduce himself to a couple of
other patterns and those in turn will
shape the future of his thinking.
Well,
don't be like me.
Dot.
Full Shit.
But you weren't,
you,
you wouldn't be making this,
this beautiful dark music man.
You know that this is something
I love about that man.
What does that song,
what was the,
uh,
the song that you played,
um,
the last time you were here,
how many different songs did you play?
The American girl,
Miss America.
Miss America has that little Miss America.
God Damn Son,
I can't think like that.
I'll start crying.
I can't,
I could never write something like that.
I would just start crying.
But I love hearing it,
you know,
like,
well that's kind of where I
take it about is what makes me,
like,
when I'm writing it,
you know,
after it's written,
and I can perform it,
you know,
I don't get as emotional,
but that's what I try and do.
I try and make myself upset a little bit.
Like feel something because I'm,
I'm hard.
Honestly.
I'm like,
I'm hard to get to,
you know,
react.
You're a big teddy bear.
Probably truth,
but it's hard to get past the,
the,
the for,
well,
you just dealt with a lot of Douche.
Douchebags it's normal.
It's normal,
you know,
search reason,
life say no,
you've,
you know,
you're about to sing right there.
Those,
let's get to have a nub
and surgeries and alive.
Go right into sampling.
Yeah.
You know?
But ultimately you're a nice guy.
I mean,
you know,
I'd like to think so.
Yeah.
He's a nice guy.
You're fun,
you're fun to be around.
And if you use your blinker,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but you've also dealt with a lot of
Douche bags were we live in douchebag
central and we work amongst douchebag.
Fucking,
you know,
in the Douche bag.
Yes.
Industry there is,
you know,
people will never know.
There's
dental douchey.
It can possibly be.
And especially the music business.
I think it's probably the Douchey,
just how to all the potential running
into dickheads running any musicians.
Like you got a lot of brilliant,
beautiful people out there,
but God damn things way worse
than musicians and Tish bags.
Yeah.
Cause even a shitty musician is
actually probably somewhat decent.
Has shitty actors this fucking,
yes.
That's a good point
because most actors are gross to begin
with and you have a shitty went on top of
that.
I would say they're pretty close.
I've met a lot of douchey musicians,
but yeah,
I think ultimately you're probably right.
I think men do.
Musicians requires more discipline to,
you know,
does it?
You have to actually,
especially if you play an instrument,
you have to actually learn discipline.
You got to practice.
Yeah,
that's a big thing.
Answers on best act is shit.
Investment in time.
Acting as easy as fuck too and they
like to pretend it's really difficult.
It's easy as well.
I think there's a level of it that's hard,
right?
I mean Daniel Day Lewis,
the general most things done in the
acting world are relatively easy.
It's not like playing guitar
and singing at the same time.
That's tricky as fuck isn't it?
And actually it took a long time
for me to be able to do both.
Yeah,
watch you do it.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm perplexed by the dam,
but the one can,
you know,
the one thing that's bad is,
like I said,
if that one kink in the road,
it's a train wreck,
man.
It's like I should have never
opened my eyes on that one.
Well that's different than a joke.
You know,
a joke.
You could fuck up in the middle of it
and sorta like re rail it and it'd be,
and you even go on a tangent
about the fuck up and you're okay,
but we'll not get set on me.
It's all pictures and one
kind of cross circuit.
And so honestly what happened was,
is my hand started playing one song and
I was saying words from another and then
it was all,
it was like just jumbled garbage.
How would we really be fascinated if
someone who was a memory expert could talk
to you about,
uh,
how you organize thoughts like how you,
how many,
how you memorize things.
I bet people could learn
a lot because you're,
you're,
there's,
you've got and just not just words,
you got words that correspond to Melanie's
correspond to musical notes and you
have it all like arrange and
I'm sure you've morphed it.
So you've probably had several versions
of each song as if sort of evolved
inside your head.
I bet that would be.
How many fucking songs do you
have in your head right now?
Like how many songs
could you reliably play?
A hundred just mean without
like rehearsing like without
a company and just you?
Well,
I kind of eliminate all
the rap songs if you,
cause that wouldn't be playing too.
So,
um,
probably most songs off of
most of my records if I,
you know,
what's the number?
60 60 or 60 think about all that shit.
60 Times what?
Five minutes for four minutes.
That's a lot of fucking shit to memorize,
son.
A lot of shit inside your head.
Just spinning around and
you're calling upon another,
you know,
three albums of wraps and
stuff I've never even used yet.
You know.
Do you think you get to bust those out
as well or would you need to a wrap
mindset?
Um,
I like the classics.
I could bust out.
Did you take any shit when you moved from
rap to like this sort of bluesy style
of music?
Nah,
cause I think some people are growing
up with me and I've never really,
I,
I was part of the cocoa notes for this
was that was a little rap collective,
you know,
and all,
every one of my records has
something hip hop related.
I still kind of consider
myself hip hop artists,
you know,
I just evolved into what I'm doing.
You know,
it's anybody who's downloaded
la Coka nostra just that name.
I don't want to get in an
argument with any of those dudes.
I don't want to be an argument
with anybody who was in
something called La Coka.
Nostra that seems like a lot,
a lot of drama that would come with that.
Just the names.
I'll just kinda cheat coco
cafe powerful cookbook.
I think something that came from one
day like where before I had joined the
group,
there was a couple of the guys who
like to a little bit and you know,
and,
and they were talking like
in the studio one day like,
Yo,
we're getting along great.
It's like La Cosa Nostra and Danny boy.
Like he was sober and he was like,
yeah,
more like La Coka Nostra and
coined the name right there that
cocaine's a mother fucker man,
that Buck Cherry Song.
That's a bad ass jam.
You know like that song.
I love the cocaine.
Yeah.
That's the best cocaine
song next to the uh,
I've never really heard,
clapped wanting to have the
issue come up cause of each,
steered away from that shit.
I mean I did a couple of times in my life,
but like it never became,
I always knew I had a little hard thing.
So I always kind of was like,
you know,
those kinds of,
those,
the maths and the in the cocaine's and
even the ecstasy and stuff like that.
I stayed heavily away from it.
About Caffeine.
I don't drink the shit.
I think I'm a coca cola fiend,
man.
I drink too.
Well,
that's my bit.
If I dressed,
if I stopped drinking coca cola alone,
Joe,
I'd probably lose 15
pounds just from that.
Why don't you stop fucking love it,
man.
Really did.
You didn't even do coke.
Zero.
You Go.
No,
I only drink coke out of a glass bottle.
Mexican coke.
Yeah.
This is what I tell people.
Think about it this way.
If you want,
they make American coax the little sorry,
but the little eight ounce
or Americans learn it.
You can find Mexican ones,
but I'll drink the
little American ones too.
If you want it.
You really change what you drink and
you really want to drink a lot of water.
Just think about how delicious water
would be if it was rare as fuck.
If water was difficult to come.
Most delicious.
Now I love ice.
Cold bottle of water.
Just pound.
Just take,
yeah,
go.
It's this.
There's that fucking monster in my brain
that tells you to get that Coca Cola
water.
I've gone on kicks where I kind of stopped
and what I do is I get club soda and
cause it's the bike that bike,
that cold bite back and that carbonated
goodness and that sugar rush and Oh
there's cups out to bad for you.
Is it bad carbon ended shit.
I heard there's something about carbonated
water that's not supposed to sodium
in it.
Is that what it is?
There's sodium in it.
Yeah.
And it might be a lot of sodium in it.
Coca Cola.
Fuck you up at that corn syrup man.
That corn syrup some and
that's why the Mexican ones,
they're a little better.
They're made with real sugar cane sugar.
How do you get those?
You're going to date sending
them all around California.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Getting California and when you get
out of California or Arizona Anyway,
it touches Mexico.
You can pretty much get them in Ohio
before they started selling the small
little ones because they stopped selling.
Sell the tall ones.
Yeah,
they stopped selling him like in Ohio.
They stopped selling all bottles for
awhile and they just recently like maybe
like seven years ago,
brought back like the
little baby bottles in Ohio.
So I used to go to antique stores and
buy the old bottles and then fill them up
with coke and put my my
refrigerator cause I'm a psycho.
Wow.
Why just because you like
drinking out of those bottles?
Yeah,
I'm the same way with him.
I love fucking coconut bar,
but some reason it just brings,
pour it in there.
Then I killed all the fizz.
Right.
No night if you'd like drink
it the same day or two.
Oh
we are.
First of all,
it's just something about it
the way glass chills it too.
It's better than than to me.
I don't like them.
I feel like I can taste metal
when I drink out of aluminum.
Okay.
Well when cans first came out
you could taste the difference.
Remember going like,
Oh this tastes weird.
Do you remember that?
Like when when [inaudible] first came out?
I don't,
but I do remember the people were
like really into this Mexican coke,
Mexican coke.
Like people were saying,
it's actually,
it just tastes better.
And it's cane sugar,
colas,
the original cocacola cause it the
actual sugar before all the corporations
bought into the corn syrup thing.
And that's all we use now in America.
Do you know the Coca Cola
is the number one like the,
as far as like important.
Like who who takes
cocaine in this country?
Coca Cola,
they,
his medical cocaine and they get medical
cocaine from processing the coca leaves
that they used to make Coca Cola.
Like they're connected with medical
costs and not know that one of the active
ingredients in Coca Cola,
they're sanctioned.
Like they were part of all these
sanctioned assassinations and Southwire,
oh my God,
go to a documentary.
I haven't dot com no joke.
Nicole's evil and,
and,
and uh,
I think it's called the Coca Cola
files or the Coca Cola cases.
And it's about how their
involvement in some like,
you know,
nefarious activities down
there in South America.
Well,
if you're going to be a coke,
I'm surprised I didn't hear about
that inside that little documentary.
They don't,
I mean,
they don't sell coke,
but they do sell to,
they take the process of
converting whatever the fuck is,
uh,
in the coca leaves into
some sort of a flavonoid,
some sort of a plant based,
a taste.
And they take that and it's one of the
ingredients of coke that makes it taste
weird.
And for the longest time
was actually cocaine.
Oh yeah.
Back original.
Coca Cola was cocaine.
But when the process that
they use to make cocaine,
yeah.
The actual process today,
and this is in 2013,
they used to make,
Coca Cola involves cocaine.
It doesn't give you a cocaine high,
but there's a flavor aspect of it that
actually comes from the coca plant.
Yeah.
And then they take that shit and they
sell it and they process it and they take
the cocaine out of it and make medical
cost counties because gang of shit used
to have cocaine.
All these little Ho you're nit Vicks.
NYQUIL would have been like
loaded with cocaine back.
Codene or Cody.
Yeah,
that stuff was bad.
How's,
why remedies like all those like cure als
where like had a little bit of cocaine
in them and say,
did you ever have the old school
nick walls with the codeine in it
some the other day?
Did you really get it?
You can still get it.
You get the Nyquil with coding?
Yeah.
You just have to get it prescribed.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I know they have prescription cough syrup,
but coding,
but I didn't know if it was nick went
on math method and it used to be able to
just go to cvs and he'd go to cvs and
you would get Nicole and I got sick once
and I'll never forget
this.
I had never taken it before,
but I got sick once and I was so happy.
I was like,
my pillow was like massaging me.
I was like call into this
pillar watching TV I've done.
I felt I never felt better.
I was like,
oh my God,
I could get it.
That can be a little chunky on this.
One of those big bottles of
that medical grade concert.
And like I kinda got into it
stretch where I was fucking with it.
And then like within a year or so,
a couple,
like at least three rappers,
I knew,
God,
it makes you feel like
you're coming for hours.
They forget,
you forget to breathe and you're sleeping.
You just stopped.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's how it just slows you down so much.
People just like,
we go to sleep and die.
That's when I was like,
there was a gang and that shit was like,
oh,
the bottle I had was like a couple grand.
I wonder if that I was going
to do with sleep apnea.
I bet it has to do with Scott out.
Cause some guy I knew like that
was a sneaker freak like me.
He worked for Sparkletts and he delivered
a sparkless deliveries into this,
to this,
uh,
to,
a dentist or a doctor's office.
And like as he was delivering it,
he went out the bat and he saw they had
a fucking case over him and he grabbed
like,
wow.
One wow,
that stuff is powerful.
It's fuck,
there was one time I spent like five
days in my house like fuck up on my shit.
Playing.
Playing socom too.
Yeah,
that stuff's legit.
There's a lot of pain stuff
that's addictive as fuck.
It's amazing today.
Five days after that we're fucking hell.
Oh I bet.
What is the withdrawal?
Headachy body.
You're just,
yeah,
you're sick.
You're basically like flu.
You feel like you got the
flu for like three days.
Wow.
So then you get more.
What does it make you want to,
is it one of those things where it makes
you want to get home after that five
day man I did it a few times after that.
Lightly within a drink or something but
like that five days I was going like
straight.
Wow.
Oh my God.
It's like never stop and being drunk.
It's like being drunk for days like your
brain is getting all that visual like a
firm cause I was like heavily
into that video game for a time.
We had like a whole team of people on it.
What it was when online shit first,
like really good,
like you know,
it was working well and so,
um,
we would just get fucked up
for days and like the Vit,
your brain's getting all this
like happiness from the visual.
And like you said,
I was in my chair just like,
oh dude,
game.
And for days I just talked
to another dude who,
uh,
had a back injury and got
hooked on Oxycontin's.
I've probably talked to maybe 10 people
that have told me that exact same story
that another dude who had
a hard time kicking in.
I just wonder,
I'm like,
how many people out there?
There's 300 million people.
How many people out there or hooked
on oxy cause a commercial right now.
And to me that's telling people about,
you know,
if you're hooked on opiates and this,
that,
and the other,
they're not advertising it.
Like 1% of the people
know they're advertising.
It's primetime.
It's like herpes meds,
Yo,
it's out there.
People in droves.
They're not advertising on
TV because it's like not,
not around.
Right,
exactly.
It's not like they're malaria pills.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You don't ever hear that on
TV.
Come back malaria pill.
Yeah.
Do you need a malaria pills?
Fix Your boner pills.
Herpes meds.
There's a lot of problems out there.
There's a lot of people hooked on pills.
I mean,
that's a man.
That's why everything else is illegal.
Of course,
pharmaceutical corporations,
they wanted us hooked on their drugs.
It's amazing how it's happened.
I mean that really is almost
like a science fiction movie.
When you look at how many
people are dependent on,
and then not only that,
how many jobs are dependent upon
the production of these things.
Young was medicine something even
advertise besides a cold medicine,
like a Nyquil or something like that.
Did you ever see advertisements
on TV for like prescription pills?
Nail fungus tell you so
many commercials that say,
ask your doctor about this.
You never used to go ask
your doctor for medicine.
They told you what fucking
medicine you needed.
Yeah,
because if you have a psychosomatic thing,
you can go in and say,
you know doc,
I saw this commercial on that.
Everybody have enough on TV?
Hey Dee Dee,
your arms hurt.
Can you move them?
Fuck,
I can't remember.
Does your hair grow?
Fuck it stopped.
Maybe you have this.
I might have it.
Look at all the symptoms like God,
I think I got it.
Shit.
And then they run really
quickly by may cause vomiting,
anal bleeding and then
you know what he was like,
what the fuck?
Who's going to actually take this?
What's so unfair?
If you know the history of people too.
It's not like they didn't know that
people have been like Roos by charlatans,
all these fucking late night preachers
that are trying to get people to donate
money.
They've been doing it for
years and years and years.
They didn't,
they already knew that there was a
certain percentage of the population that
were like super easily manipulated.
So to make them responsible for,
you know,
their own judgment and
having a commercial on that,
selling prescription drugs,
that's really ridiculous.
That's not just the guys you got now you
got guys coming in asking for stuff and
how many doctors are just sleazebags.
I mean,
we've learned how many doctors
used to be when we were young.
That was a,
somebody like,
uh,
you were told policemen,
firemen,
doctors,
these are good people.
We know.
Now that's not true.
There are people there,
they're just as dirty and
rotten as everybody else.
So how many of them are like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll prescribe you all that shit.
Oh,
it's happening.
For sure.
I could go out right now,
legitimately right now with,
by the end of,
well,
it's probably late today,
but by the end of day tomorrow I can have
pri five prescriptions for painkillers
if I really want them.
Well,
today in California there's a database,
so you could probably go to different
doctors and maybe get different things
prescribed.
Sure.
Yeah.
Not the same one.
But in Florida,
they don't have a database.
I mean,
they might've changed it now,
but they had that,
that show,
the oxycontin express that they aired.
If you,
you can just Google that online,
you can watch it.
It's,
um,
the,
what does that,
I think it was on true TV,
but either way,
whatever it was on the
Oxycontin Express van guard,
that was the show they went and they
showed how you could go to Florida.
You can go to a doctor,
say,
oh my back hurts.
They give you a prescription and you
go down the street to another doctor.
He gives you a prescription
for the same shit.
Nobody talks to anybody.
They don't,
there's not a database that they can say,
hey Mr. Wilson,
I see you've had 10,000 oxycontin
prescriptions from different doctors this
year.
So because of that,
Florida sells more oxycontin
then the whole country,
like literally think that the numbers
for how much the part of your whole
explanation of Florida's crazy.
Now it's absolutely,
let me make sure that that's true
because someone told me that,
uh,
Florida uses more oxy
than the whole country.
Yeah.
Cause there's a doubt in my mind,
Brian,
when he thinks that,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
I think it's right.
Yeah.
Uh,
it doesn't sound wrong.
It doesn't sound wrong.
Yeah.
Well either way I'll,
I'll look for it.
While we're talking,
but the,
uh,
the reality is that there's a lot of
fucking people that take that shit and
they're gone.
It's,
it's,
it's opiate.
It's really dangerously
addictive and they just,
they just toss and I never took it.
Somebody gave me some once and I just,
they actually frightened me.
I threw them away because I knew so many
people that just got caught out there
so quickly on them.
Well,
you ready for this?
In Florida alone,
almost 3000 people died
of an overdose in 2009.
2010.
The majority of these people
had legal prescriptions,
medications,
and their systems at the time of death.
Wow.
That's Nutty Shit,
man.
They're just dropping like flies.
3000 people,
man,
that's nine 11.
That's nine 11.
And it's,
it's,
it's happening all the time.
It's nine 11 and it keeps going.
People just dropping this show was really
scary because one of the guys on the
show,
his wife had died of an overdose and
he got high before you called the cops.
His wife was lying next to him,
cold and blue and this motherfucker got
high before he called the ambulance.
Hmm.
That's how crazy it is.
Yeah.
That shit honestly scared me.
It's terrifying.
I had a period where I was like heavy and
they're like taking like biking in and
drinking a few whiskeys.
Oh,
why don't you like to do that?
What does that feeling made me feel.
I would take like half a viking
and my rule was a half a Vicodin
and then I can have a few
whiskeys and it'd be like,
it'd be almost the same feeling as that,
that crop syrup.
Like you ever do that by
if I get into and Whiskey,
yeah,
I've done Vegan is alcohol.
What does it like?
It's
really slow and yeah,
it's like,
it's kind of like,
yeah,
it's like comfortable.
It's like tripping on
the Robo trafficking.
I had a buddy who was a guitar player who
said that vicodins made him like super
creative love vicodins maybe?
No,
maybe.
you don't think something.
It's never happened to me.
Viking I've signed,
it makes me pretty lazy on them.
I was pretty lazy on them.
Wow,
that's interesting.
We just wanted it like,
yeah,
I'm good.
Okay.
Some,
you know,
call up abroad or something.
Rod [inaudible] from the fifties Calib
Rudd scally cap on calling up abroad
while I listened to see if I watch
those old movies where dudes of backhand
bitches.
Yeah.
And you're like,
whoa.
They go off and that was that going
on where you can put it in a movie.
We get to the Moon Alice.
Yeah.
We,
well that he never actually hit her.
He was threatening her.
It was,
he was right when you think about it,
pow to the out,
right in
the kisser.
Yeah.
He was gonna Punch her kid a
mood and he was a big guy too.
The nose,
I'm going to punch you in the face
and Jackie Gleason seemed like cyber.
Do we punch a check?
Do you ever see that Sean Connery
interview we talked about,
sometimes women need a slap
cause they keep pushing.
Sometimes you have to slap him.
Everybody was like,
Whoa,
God Damn Sean Connery.
But the way he was saying is like,
listen,
never had a broad pushing
that button on you.
Oh yeah.
No,
I don't think he meant every,
I mean that's the,
that's probably asking me.
Yeah,
I'm asking.
My Dad beat my mom and I had a very,
very similar to that.
My father was an alcoholic.
I'm,
I'm very scared of that.
I have getting into any sort
of a domestic situation.
So No,
I've never had,
I had one.
Have you ever hit what I'm just saying?
But it never had a broad come at you.
Like she was pushing to a point where she
wanted you to slap the shit out of her
or do something physical to her?
No,
I had to duck,
man.
I just like,
I've never,
it never got to the crazy rods.
I've liked a lot of crazy birds too,
but I have a little bit,
I have a little bit of a higher threshold
before I press the panic button and
subscribe to the Chris Rock Dairy,
which was,
I won't hit a bitch,
but I'll shoot the shit.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
my whole life when I was a young man was
all dedicated to martial arts and the
last thing I ever wanted to do is getting
a violent altercation with a girl.
But I had chick swing at me.
I've had a couple of girls I
dated like make them the same.
They know there's,
there's broads who want that to happen,
but I've never gotten even close.
I'm not willing to enter.
That's,
that's the sign to get the fuck away.
Right,
and what have you like it?
Yeah.
What are some chick comes after you when
you fucking cracker and all of a sudden
you're in your,
you're like,
all right,
well I started hitting you.
Here we go.
You know,
we're actually fighting now.
And then your plumbing or,
and Nina in the face and pounded
her into the ground mean,
what the fuck are you doing?
You gonna fight like what are you going
to get a halfway fight and you going to
shaker,
you're going to slap her.
How hard do you slap her?
Can You punch her?
If she punches you?
What'd she grabs you,
Dick.
And she won't let go.
You're going to punch you then like what
happens then and then if she gets out
of it now you're asking questions and
know if you're going to ask me to pray and
I'm going to say I'm really
good at subscribe to like,
I'll tell you the same way I heard him
say it in American pimp there a time and
a place to hit anyone.
Yes.
In defending yourself
and defending your lab.
So if you're saying if she grabbed
your Dick and won't let go,
you're getting punched dead in your,
sure.
Psychologically we tried
to torture me or something.
I'm going to do everything I can
to get the fuck away from me.
That's when I just,
I don't have a desire to hit anybody
when they're psychologically tortured,
but I come from the same thing.
My father,
you know,
he wasn't,
he was like a binge alcoholic like can
be find for nine months and then a bump
in the road and he'd be gone for three,
four weeks,
come home.
And by the time I hit 1617 I,
you know,
the data steer you away in any way
from alcohol or make you wary of it.
Well,
yeah,
very wary of it.
I mean it never steered me away.
I was always drinking,
but I just never,
I never drank by myself.
It was always early on in my life.
I was very aware of that kind
of stuff.
Like don't be caught drinking at home.
Don't drink because you're
sad or in a bad mood.
I know that's not my thing.
Yeah.
That's never the good mood.
Like drink it for me,
it's something I do like,
oh we're going to go
out and have some fun.
Let's have a few drinks.
That's cool that you were able to
overcome that even though your dad had an
issue.
Because sometimes at that that thing is
either psychological but sometimes it's
genetic,
you know,
but like by the time I hit 1516 I would,
my routine was like I
would when I knew those,
cause they're,
like I said,
it was like it wasn't
an every night thing.
It's about,
I guess he'd be fine for a long time,
but when you knew he was on a binge,
I would stay up every night till either
he didn't come home or he came home,
sit them down and give him some food
just to keep it from like fighting.
And then like one time,
you know,
he started trying to fight with my mom,
but I was saying I was
about 1617 and I just,
that's when I stepped in and
fucked up.
So we had a fight and you know,
I woke up on the couch later.
My Dad was a big construction work in man.
So,
you know,
he wasn't easy to fight,
but that was the last time flew
out to when me and him squared off.
It was the last time it
ever happened to him.
He never did it again.
And then they finally split
up a little while later.
Yeah.
That's not good man.
Being around crazy big drunks that
can beat the fuck outta here was never
willing to,
you know what?
Before he passed though,
I think he got it together.
He was,
he came,
you know,
his life lessons were learned,
you know what I mean?
Well,
the alcohol one is such a fucked up one
because it seems some sort of a chemical
thing goes off and some folks,
and then he died at 63 I
know it shortened his life.
Of course.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
It's poison.
I mean it feels good because it's poison.
Poison.
You know your shit.
But Damn,
it's fun.
Sometimes whiskeys good.
And the relief,
the relief from the burdens of thinking
about all the subtle nuances of the
world,
you know,
when did you just like,
who gives a fuck?
Let's do another shot.
You clink glasses and you know that
everybody's all in on it with you.
That's good stuff.
It's good stuff when it goes
the other way from there.
If you're not,
if that's not how you're doing it,
you shouldn't be doing it.
Exactly.
But again,
it boils down to who you're doing it with.
Unless you're an alcoholic,
then it pause down there.
Sorry,
you got a shitty gene.
He got some American Indian and Irish.
I shouldn't,
you know what I mean?
I kind of,
I'm sure there's some genetic
level of connection to it,
but it's choice,
man.
There's a big choice there.
You can choose,
you can,
you can choose not to.
If I,
if I really suspected I was like
fucked up like my father was,
I would've just chose to never drink.
You know what I mean?
Because I was so hyperconscious I,
cause I was able to see also the pattern.
My father's father was,
my father was a good father
compared to his father.
You know what I mean?
My father made improvements so I can see.
I said,
okay,
so it's my turn to make that improvement.
That's exactly the same with my father.
My father's father was
even more of a savage.
He came over from Ireland
during the depression and
my mom told me that when she
was young,
my dad's dad tried to fuck her.
Like she was,
she was like when she'd already had me,
like she'd be over the house
and my father would step,
I'm gonna go down the corner
and my dad would be like,
in my dad's father would be like,
what's up?
What's up?
You want some of this?
And she'd be like,
what the fuck?
Kind of crazy family is this just
drunk savages from the depression?
Those were people that were
worried about starving to death.
Those are people that would take
a piece of pussy in a heartbeat.
They were,
they were,
they were rapist and savages.
There were animals.
They took a fucking boat
ride across the world.
The wind up in some place where
they never even saw a picture of it.
They had no idea what was going
to be like landed on a boat,
God out and we're hey,
made their way.
Yeah,
we're hated.
Hated,
made their way.
This is so much closer to animals.
Hence the back fest woman Schmuck,
you know,
that's from the 1950s
that she was acceptable.
People were crazy back then.
They were fucking animals.
The crazy now,
but the better,
right.
Hopefully,
I figured there's no Rogan's any sign.
If he has any proof that
culture is evolving.
It's the proof in our record of culture.
I'm our songs,
our,
our movies.
You know,
our standup comedy,
you know,
you want to see the,
the evolution of culture in the,
in standup comedy.
So a good microcosm.
It's good way to look at
the evolution of culture.
Go back and try to watch like some old
comedy from the 1950s and sixties it's so
dated.
Even if you can put yourself into that
mindset and see the brilliance of it.
It's so dated,
you know,
watch some Lenny Bruce tried to laugh.
That's how as edgy as he was,
he was the greatest.
He opened up all the doors,
but you can't wash that shit today.
It's weird in Carlene's still some of it,
some of it,
some of it is still dated though.
If you go to the really old stuff priors,
the first guy to me that's universal,
like he's,
he stands the test of time he's at,
he's evergreen.
His,
his shit.
His shit was so like raw.
Like when he would talk about his life
and the way he would describe things was
so raw that I think to
this day still resonates.
Yeah.
I remember the first time watching
it live on the sunset strip.
Fuck yeah.
It wasn't supposed to be watching it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It was in the movie theater.
The guy was just talking and
everybody was dying laughing.
That was a,
that was a game changer
for a lot of people.
That was the first time a lot of people
got to see comedy like that created a
whole generation of comics,
man,
that sure.
A little era.
He was the first really honest guy.
Well,
him and Lenny Bruce,
Lenny Bruce was the first
really honest guy too,
but,
but not when it came to
his personal life prior.
Took it to a completely different
level than anybody had before.
You know?
I love that movie too.
Joe.
Joe Dancing.
We got to wrap this up with
one with one or two more.
Which ones do you want to play?
Well,
it's up to you.
I want it told you I play one.
Yeah,
I want,
I got to hear that one.
And then maybe one more
that you want to do.
Is that cool?
Figure it out.
Okay.
Beautiful.
And if any little punks on Twitter
complaining that he's playing music,
I need you to go fuck yourself right now,
okay.
And listen and get your mind straight,
bitches.
We're so backed.
Oh Gee.
Everlast follow
him on Twitter.
Uh,
[inaudible]
ain't
you
don't
mind.
Yes
ma'am.
Shy
that
style.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah,
indeed.
Powerful.
Everlast Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm getting my Mojo back.
Bitches now from their last one.
It's still bothered.
Gotta let it go,
my friend.
Oh,
we've got to move forward.
I'm there.
I'm there as well.
What?
Let me do,
what does it,
what is it?
Like black on black coffee.
Okay.
We do that yet though.
Did I do that?
You know what,
today we'll wrap it up,
but this will take it home with this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for tuning in.
God bless you all and in
your own special burger.
Beautiful,
perfect way.
We're going to do this.
Go fuck yourselves.
Uh,
why people are mad.
Be Cool.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck God.
Damn.
Show.
Tell him to go fuck themselves.
That's not a bad,
I don't even pay attention to that stuff.
No one's mad,
man.
Oh one.
Yeah,
we go
yes.
Today.
Just a dream.
I don't remember.
Marow Stylo Barb yet to
Matt of town out of Ram.
Anna Marie's
seasons change.
Leave me out in the cold
stone is old man is Skyler's
Dallas
pocket
cry
trying to sell,
but no one's by
last name it.
Damn man.
Good Tab.
My watchman shine.
Now Word Man Lo
whap Smith.
Lao Word Man.
Watch me shine.
Yeah,
man's free from sin.
Cast the first stone.
Ghana.
Yeah,
true.
Speak on up till this fall.
Spring to the Saturday.
Yep.
The News daily lives.
See is one movie in the Sunshine
Rec.
Now his pass doopy lag time.
Wow.
Lao world
stay
watch mission.
Hello world and man.
No,
stay.
Watch me shine
with the crowns.
Watch me please.
Yeah,
Matt,
you can always get
Mao.
Will is turn
to the to
watch ms shine.
Laughs.
Watch me.
Watch me shy.
Boom.
That was beautiful.
That was fucking beautiful.
Goddammit.
Thank you sir.
Macular shit.
It's over now.
Now you've erased it.
Blew the exercise.
All the demon,
all of them are gone.
It's a fuck up.
But you're used,
he's having,
there's a couple of times like a strap
would break onstage and guitar and it's
like you know what people,
it's real right it Israel.
Exactly.
Now you can set that at least it wasn't
like the first time on the first one
that I did that at least
I'm three times beat.
People know I can,
I can.
I got what I got and I fuck I fucked
went up cause Joe answered his phone.
People love the fuck
out of here is my fault.
It's 100% I want to see if you
catch any flack on Twitter.
I've already have.
I'm sure I apologize to you.
I apologize to all the
beautiful people on Twitter.
I apologize.
The stamps.com for what I did.
Go to stamps.com using code word GRE
and get a beautiful special offer.
I think they come to your
house and rub your balls.
We start at Humber.
No,
I don't think that's,
that's not the case anymore.
That's a,
we should start a tunnel level.
Tramp stamps.com.
Do you like tramp stamps?
Like a funny website.
Tramp stamp that stamps I've ever seen
the one that's like chicks with Steve
Buscemi is'.
Yeah.
That was just fucking rude.
No,
it's fucking disturbing.
I don't want to say it's more disturbing
than game of Thrones last night.
Oh,
don't talk stop.
Don't say a word.
Oh,
you ain't saying oh yeah.
I love it,
dude.
I'm too,
I'm too behind.
I gotta catch up tonight.
Don't please.
I don't want to get Marty avoidant.
Hey,
we love the fuck are you guys.
Thank you very much.
Great show right now.
Caught up show O.
N.
I t use a code name and save some cash.
Oh Gee.
Everlast on Twitter.
Follow even with the banks.
Enjoy Raven Tobacco was so much
on my keyboard player Brian,
when that was going and
go blow up at Twitter.
Joe Rogan.
How do it,
how do we [inaudible] Raven Rov,
da Da da.
Raven.
Dot banger.
Dub anger or black beauty.
Black beauty.
That's it.
You're black.
Beauty.
Oh,
is that your Twitter?
You got a Twitter is black beauty is
beauty at the bang or I don't know how to,
or is it lack beauty?
Yeah.
Some rapper will stone.
He came over to my house.
He said my hair was long and black,
so he's like,
you're like black beauties.
Is that guy trying to fuck you?
I certainly hope not.
Did he give you that?
Dolphins?
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good night.
We'll see tomorrow.
Tom Rhodes in the house.
That story,
the next part that I'm confused already.
Okay.